Die zwei Sprechstunden. Hat es sich an diesem 26.04.
Der wie immer, so ist es Tradition, am letzten Donnerstag im Monat übernommen wird quasi von einer fremden Macht, die sich Chaos Computer Club nennt und zu Gast ist heute Henrik vom Chaos Computer Club. Hallo und guten Abend.
Hallo.
Und eigentlich auch noch jemand anderes, nämlich die Tina. Wir kämpfen hier allerdings noch mit technischen Problemen, ob wir die noch beseitigt kriegen, ich weiß es ja nicht so genau. Worum soll es heute gehen? Also ganz kurz um Pferde, ein bisschen länger. Es ist ja hier oft so, dass es um technische Themen geht, dass die Hacker ankommen und sagen, hier guck mal, wir haben da etwas Neues auseinandergekommen und neu wieder zusammengesetzt. Und darum soll es heute auch gehen, wurde mir gesagt, aber eher in einem kulturellen Sinne. Es geht darum, dass bestimmte Dinge in der Hacker-Kultur ja gerade sehr beliebt sind, also vor allen Dingen Fernsehserie, Bücher oder Thematiken. Und diese Dinge werden dann auseinandergenommen und wieder neu zusammengesetzt und das heißt dann Fanfiction. Und damit werden wir uns heute ein bisschen beschäftigen. Es gibt Fanfiction schon sehr lange, also manche Leute sagen, die Bibel sei die erste, aber das ist vielleicht ein anderes Thema. Nee, aber Star Trek oder Star Wars kennt ihr bestimmt und da gibt es also hunderttausend Leute, die sich im Netz und sonst wo schon immer zusammengesetzt haben und gesagt haben, so hier, man müsste diese Geschichte noch mal weiter spinnen, das könnte doch irgendwie vielleicht noch anders sein. Star Wars gibt das sogar in Büchern dann irgendwann und es gibt natürlich für jede erfolgreiche Fernsehserie gibt es im Netz auch irgendwo etwas, was mit diesen Dingen zu tun hat. Über dieses Fanfictioning würde ich gerne mit der Tina sprechen, die aber anscheinend noch nicht am Start ist. Wir werden die mal versuchen ranzukriegen und hören währenddessen eine Musik, die vielleicht einen kleinen Vorgeschmack auf das gibt, worum es heute außerdem noch so gehen wird. So, da war der erste Ausblick in das, was uns heute Abend möglicherweise noch erwarten wird. Es geht nämlich noch um kleine bunte Pferde. Also wir versuchen jetzt noch mal, ob wir möglicherweise die Tina jetzt am Start haben. Hallo Tina? Schweigen in der Leitung. Wir haben heute etwas völlig Neuartiges versucht hier im Chaosradio. Wir wollten Voice-over-IP probieren, diese neue Raketentechnologie, wo man...
Also eigentlich eher Skype.
Ich wollte es jetzt nicht so sagen. Diese Raketentechnik, die anscheinend nicht immer funktioniert... Immerhin das Auflegegeräusch war da, das ist auch schön. Dann nehmen wir die Tino übers Telefon. Hallo und guten Abend, Tina. Ja, das scheint nur so zu funktionieren, was sehr schade ist, aber irgendwas ist ja immer. Wir haben uns schon... Ich habe schon kurz angekündigt, es soll heute um Fanfiction gehen. Du hast dich mit diesem Thema ja ausführlicher beschäftigt.
Ja, für geringe Werte von ausführlich, aber ja so ein bisschen.
Warum gibt es sowas und was passiert da?
Fanfiction ist quasi fanbasiertes Schreiben. Und zwar geht es da meistens um die Figuren einer Fernsehserie, eines Comics, eines Films. Und es wird innerhalb dieses Kanons, also dieser Figurenkonstellation und innerhalb des Universums dieser ursprünglichen Figuren werden neue Geschichten erfunden. Und manchmal werden die Figuren auch weiterentwickelt. Bei Slashfiction geht es dann in die romantische oder sexuelle Richtung. Und bei der Fanfiction ist es dann aber auch vor allen Dingen, dass neue Geschichten erfunden werden.
Jetzt gerade diese Slashfiction ist ja nicht uninteressant. Kannst du kurz erklären, warum das Slashfiction heißt?
Das heißt Slashfiction, weil der Slash sozusagen die Pärchen voneinander trennt. Also die erste Slashfiction oder eins der berühmtesten Beispiele von Slashfiction ist ja Kirk und Spock und Kirk, Slash, Spock wurden die dann immer genannt und deswegen hat sich das so eingebürgert, dass man das Slashfiction nennt.
Das ist ja eine spannende Frage, die mir sofort einfällt, ist, wenn ich jetzt Fanfiction schreibe über so ein Idol aus einer Geschichte, würde ich eher vermuten, die romantischen Tendenzen kommen dann sozusagen vom Schreiber gegenüber der Figur. Wieso verkuppeln die dann Charaktere miteinander?
Also die Charaktere werden miteinander verkuppelt, weil die Community, die Gemeinschaft, da sozusagen eine sexualisierte Ebene über den Kanon legt, die im Kanon nicht vorhanden ist. Das ist zum einen aus Frust darüber, dass viele Fernsehserienbücher einfach so ein bisschen entsexualisiert werden. Also man denke an Star Trek Next Generation, wo einfach überhaupt nichts passiert die ganze Zeit und man denkt sie, man jetzt knutscht doch mal oder macht doch mal was und es passiert einfach nichts, weil es halt irgendwie Family Fun und Nachmittagsfernsehen und so. Und die Fans nehmen dann so ein bisschen das Geschehen in die eigenen Hände und sagen so, jetzt machen wir mal irgendwie richtig hier Action. Und das ist dann so ein bisschen Community-basiert auch tatsächlich der Fall.
Ist das dann auch sozusagen der Punkt, wo es diese Berührung mit dem Hackertum hat, dass sozusagen die Community nimmt die Dinge in die Hand, bricht sie auf und macht sie nochmal neu?
Ich bin mir nicht so richtig sicher, inwiefern Fanfiction und Slashfiction Berührung mit dem Hackertum hat. Es hat auf jeden Fall Berührungspunkte mit dem Nerd-Tum, weil man sich sehr, sehr intensiv mit dem Kanan, also mit den Originalgeschichten und den Originalfigurenkonstellationen auseinandersetzen muss. Man muss da sehr, sehr tief in diese Geschichten eindringen, um überhaupt Fanfiction zu entwickeln. Und jetzt ruft mich gerade eure Schnittstelle an. Und ich weiß aber nicht, ob die mich hören. Hallo Schnittstelle, könnt ihr mich hören?
Wir versuchen das hier nochmal parallel auf meinem Kanal. Sag nochmal was.
Ich sage jetzt mal was.
Ja, kommt leider wieder nur übers Telefon, aber nicht über das komische Skype.
Warte mal, ich habe da aber noch... Wie ist es jetzt?
Der Watter.
Einen davon musst du ausmachen.
Verrückt. Ja leider ist das noch schlimmer als das Telefon. Es war ein Versuch wert, in der Tat. Gut, live ausprobieren, Skype im Radio, das hatten wir glaube ich auch noch nicht. Finde ich aber gut, dass man das mal macht. Diese neue Technologie, die müssen ja auch erforscht werden.
Ja, Raketentechnologie funktioniert leider nicht. Schade.
Irgendjemand muss ja... Ach so, beim Verbindung zum Nördtum. Also du meinst, ist dieses typische, man geht da rein und macht es mit aller Kraft.
Ja, also du musst dich halt sehr intensiv damit auseinandersetzen. Und das hat so ein bisschen Berührungspunkte mit dem Nörttum. Weil du auch beim Nörttum hast du ja auch dieses, ich setze mich sehr, sehr intensiv ganz, ja, ganz, also eins single-mindedly sozusagen mit einem Thema auseinander. Oder Henrik, wie siehst du das?
Ja, das ist die eigentliche Definition von Nörttum, dass man, und auch eine Entschuldigung, die man als Nerd hat, dass man sich mit etwas auseinandersetzen darf und die sämtliche, restliche Welt vergessen darf.
Gibt es denn jetzt im Chaos-Unfeld sozusagen besondere Anfälligkeiten in dieser Hinsicht? Also ich würde jetzt zippen so, okay, Star Trek, na klar.
Also im Chaos-Unfeld würde ich das jetzt vielleicht nicht sehen. Es gibt da gemeinsame Ursprünge.
Computeraffine Leute, dass es mich dann so sagen.
Ja, ich denke, es gibt da gemeinsame Faktoren. Das mag durchaus der Fall sein.
Vor allen Dingen, weil es ja auch meistens Serien sind, die durchaus auch Nerd-Appeal haben. Also wenn man jetzt mal Doctor Who und Sherlock und Star Trek und so. Aber es gibt eigentlich für ziemlich alle Fanfiction.
Warte, warte, warte. Nicht so schnell. Welche waren das jetzt?
Es gibt relativ viel Fanfiction zu nerd-affinen Serien, sag ich mal. Zum Beispiel Doctor Who und Sherlock und Star Trek.
Star Trek haben möglicherweise viele Hörer schon gehört, aber Doctor Who und Sherlock vielleicht doch noch mal kurz erklären, was das ist. Weil ich vermute, es gibt an den UKW-Empfangsgeräten einige Leute, die nicht wissen, was diese Serien sind, worum es da geht.
Also Sherlock ist eine moderne BBC, also englisches Fernsehen-Adaption von den Sherlock Holmes Geschichten. Sherlock Holmes ist da, also das ist eine relativ moderne Geschichte. Da geht es also darum, dass da viel im Internet auch gemacht wird. Also John Watson ist zum Beispiel nicht mehr sein Dokumentar, sondern er ist ein Blogger. Und Sherlock kann auch Computer und Telefone bedienen. Oh Wunder. Und das ist schon relativ, wie soll ich sagen, homoerotisch aufgebaut.
Also die beiden wohnen halt zusammen?
Bitte, die wohnen zusammen. Und da werden auch die ganzen Zeit so Anspielungen gemacht. Und naja, natürlich brauchen wir ein zweites Schlafzimmer und so. Also das hat schon so ein bisschen so ein viel. Also da ist gar nicht mehr so viel zum Slashfiction zu tun, sondern das ist schon quasi so.
Aber es gibt da dann halt auch genau diese Linie, die nicht überschritten wird, zumindest nicht in der Ausstrahlung, weil man das halt nicht machen kann im Fernsehen?
Na ja, ich glaube nicht, dass die das nicht machen, weil sie es nicht machen können, sondern weil sie einfach total das super finden, mit ihren Fans so zu spielen. Also Sherlock ist auch dafür bekannt, dass die mit ihren Fans tatsächlich in Kontakt sind und auch die Schauspieler mit ihren Fans in Kontakt sind. Und das gibt dann ganz interessante Rückkopplungseffekte.
Jetzt war das andere Dr. Who, worum geht es da?
Henry, kannst du das mal erklären?
Also Dr. Who ist auch eine britische Serie, ich glaube ich sehe da ein Muster. Also eine britische Serie, die seit, Gott jetzt muss ich überfantasieren, 50ern, 60ern irgendwie, also seit Ewigkeiten existiert, eigentlich ein rein britisches Phänomen ist außerhalb Großbritanniens kaum bekannt. Außer halt in absoluten Fankreisen. Also die gab es halt damals. Der Doktor ist ein Alien, ein zeitreisendes Alien. Ein Timelord, ja. Was halt als Beschreibung für Leute, die nicht wissen, was es ist, ein zeitreisendes Alien ist. Der in einem Raumschiff, einem Zeitschiff durch die Gegend reist, in Form einer blauen Polizeitelefonzelle. Eine der Besonderheiten, die sie damals eingebaut haben, als sie den Schauspieler wechseln mussten, was ja in manchen Serien häufiger mal passiert, ist, dass der Doktor sich regenerieren kann, eine komplett andere Form und Personalität annimmt. Was halt sehr nett ist, wenn man mal im Verlaufe des Laufes eine Serie Schauspieler austauschen möchte. Der Doktor nimmt sich auch immer einen Companion, sodass man auch den immer mal wieder austauschen kann. Und es wird dann halt gezählt in der so und so vielte Doktor, also der erste Doktor, der zweite Doktor, der dritte Doktor und so weiter. Und ich glaube, die ersten acht oder so Doktoren sind halt damals, dann gab es zwischendurch eine kurze längere Pause und neu aufgelegt wurde die Serie. Jetzt schwimme ich wieder, ich glaube, 2008, 2005 schon? Ich hätte ja 2008 gesagt, aber so in dem Dreh. Da gab es dann halt neun Doktoren, etwas Kurzlebigen und dann noch zwei Doktoren hintendran, die jetzt mehr so aktuell sind. Es ist ein bisschen unklar, Science-Fiction, ja schon, es sind immer sehr wilde Plots, es geht quer durch die Zeit, wobei aus unerfindlichen Gründen, hauptsächlich in current day, also im aktuellen Londonesspiel, sehr merkwürdig für eigentlich jemanden, der überall hinreisen kann.
Also es ist sehr abgehoben, man möchte den eigentlich immer schütteln und sagen, oh Gott, was machst du mit dem Zeit- und Raumcontinuum, also das ist für Science-Fiction-Fans eine neue Art, sich dem Genre auch zu nähern.
Und der aktuelle Schreiber Moffat ist halt auch unter Fans sehr beliebt und gehasst, weil er immer sehr schöne Twists und so weiter einbaut.
Genau, der macht übrigens auch Sherlock, also das ist der gleiche Mensch.
Entschuldigung, also worüber reden das, quasi die Fernsehserien eines einzelnen Schreibers?
In den beiden Fällen schon, ja. Also es gibt tatsächlich immer so Schreiber, die eine Fangemeinde um sich herum versammeln, egal wer sie sind, was sie tun, also Moffat oder Joss Whedon zum Beispiel, die irgendwie, ich weiß nicht woran es liegt, einen eigenen Stil haben oder irgendwas einbauen können in die Serie, was Leute fasziniert.
Jetzt gerade also diese Nummer mit dem Timeloud klingt ja tatsächlich so, als ob man, wenn der sich sozusagen immer neu entstehen kann, als ob da eine unendliche Möglichkeit gibt, sich neue Figuren auszudenken. Wird das dann gemacht oder werden dann bestehende Figuren verwendet, um sozusagen damit noch Schindluder oder Spaß zu treiben?
Sich muss zugeben, dass ich bei Sherlock nicht auf dem aktuellen Stand bin, aber es gibt da Nebenfiguren, den Captain Jack Hardness.
Hab ich Sherlock gesagt? Ich meinte Dr. Who.
Dr. Who, ja den meinte ich jetzt auch. Hab ich jetzt tatsächlich quasi höre, was du meinst nicht, was du sagst. Genau bei Dr. Who, es gibt die Nebenfigur des Captain Jack Hardness, der wohl auch in der Fangemeinde sehr beliebt ist, weil er aus homoerotischen Gesichtspunkten und ich glaube auch viel der Fanfiction spielt darum. Tina kannst du da...
Dr. Who Fanfiction, das ist jetzt so meine Sprachstelle, da weiß ich nie so irre viel drüber. Ich weiß, dass das Dr. Who erst so mit dem elften Doktor überhaupt, da ging es dann erstmal um, also er hat ja dann auch ein Kind und irgendwie lalala und hast du nicht gesehen und so und hat dann auch eine Liebesbeziehung mit seinem Raumschiff. Ja, na klar, also das ist Kanon, das ist alles da drin, also die Tardis wird menschlich und dann hat er auch eine Liebesbeziehung mit ihr und so, also das ist das sicherlich nun Kanon, das muss man sich nicht ausdenken, das ist da schon drin, aber wenn sowas da halt schon drin ist, ist klar, dass die Fangemeinde da auch in diese Richtung gerne weiterdenkt. Das ist ja auch spannend, sich da noch mal zu überlegen, weil viel von Dr. Who geht einfach nicht um diese Liebesbeziehung. Also auch die Companions, die er hat, sind ganz, also jetzt gerade mal der neunte und zehnte Doktor, die haben einfach auch keine Liebesbeziehung zu ihren Companions. Und die Beziehung, die wird nur sehr, sehr subtil angedeutet. Und da ist einfach auch so ein bisschen das Gefühl, da könnte doch jetzt mal ein bisschen mehr passieren, denke ich auch ausschlaggebend, Fanfiction zu schreiben.
Gibt es denn auch Fanfiction, die diesen Bereich verlassen hat, also wo man dann sagt, okay, das hat mal zwar ein Fan aus dieser Motivation ausgeschrieben, aber die hat es denn richtig geschafft?
Ja, es gibt zurzeit eins, das auch relativ breit in den Medien gerade die Runde macht, und das ist Fifty Shades of Grey. Das ist ursprünglich gewesen ein Fanfiction zu Twilight. Also wir erinnern uns, Twilight ist Edward, der Glitzwende Vampir und Bella, die sehr, sehr, sehr passive junge Dame.
Mit den vielen Gesichtsausdrücken?
Im Buch ist sie vor allen Dingen passiv und macht sich Gedanken über ihren Körper und dass sie irgendwie so hässlich ist und dass irgendwie keiner sie haben will und so und wartet halt auf Edward. Und da gab es einen Fanfiction, einen relativ ausführlichen, der jetzt als Trilogie veröffentlicht wurde, der ist auch auf Bestsellerlisten gelandet und der Autor wurde auch dann irgendwann mal auf irgendeine dieser 100 wichtigsten Autorenlisten gehoben, wo dann alle anderen Autoren irgendwie Sturm liefen und sagen, er ist ein fanfiction Schreiber, wie kann denn der und so. Also ja, es passiert durchaus, aber das ist relativ zild.
Okay, das ist die Stelle, wo ich euch aufrufen möchte, also euch dort draußen an den Neuheitigen Grundfunk-Empfangsgeräten, falls ihr eine Serie kennt, wo ihr sagen wollt, da müsste man auch noch mal bei Fanfiction reden, gerne hier anrufen. Oder möglicherweise habt ihr selber Fanfiction geschrieben. 031 70 97 110 So Tina, jetzt noch mal.
Ja, Slashfiction, les uns eure Slashfiction vor, bitte.
Also es gibt ja dann auch nicht nur nicht nur geschrieben Werke. Ich erinnere mich dunkel, da war auch mal was mit Star Wars, wo dann also Leute mit, weil du schon sagst, neuartigen Rundfunkempfangsgeräten, das sind ja auch Produktionsgeräte, sich wirklich hingesetzt haben und eine relativ qualitativ sehr gute, quasi selbstgeschriebene Art Star Wars, also im Star Wars Universum spielende Film, Kurzfilm gebaut haben. Das gibt es auch. Das ist so crossover Fanfiction, genau. Babylon 5 und Star... Moment. Star Trek, doch, doch, das war schon. Ja, in der Tat Star Trek. Es gibt aber auch tatsächlich eine, ich hab's auch vor zwei Jahren glaube ich mal kurz gesehen, auch eine gut computergenerierte und zusammengebaute Star Wars Geschichte. Weiß ich jetzt aber auch gar nicht mehr, wie die hieß. Aber ja, Starwreck in the Perkinning ist natürlich auch deswegen sehr wichtig, weil es viel Zusammenarbeit mit Fans gab. Also das ist ja ein irgendwie jahrelanges Projekt, wo sie dann auch Komparsen und so weiter sich zusammengesucht haben unter ihren Fans und dann so lustige Geschichten erzählen können, wie das sie das Polizeianruf gab bei der finnischen Polizei, das sind Finnen, weil Leute beobachtet haben, wie ein paar, so ungefähr 100 Leute, 100 bewaffnete Leute aus dem finnischen Parlament zu marschieren. Was halt dieser Filmdreh war, die waren also mit Wasserpistolen bewaffnet und haben halt für den Film... Die Polizei hat sich das dann mal angeguckt und hat sich dann lustig in die Ecke gestellt. Also das war halt irgendwie eine 5-Jahres-Arbeit oder so. Die meisten Szenen haben sie dann irgendwie bei sich selbst gedreht. Fast alles Blue-Screen irgendwo in ihrer ganz kleinen Wohnung und dann zusammengerendert.
Ist es denn eigentlich so, diese Fanfiction, die benutzt ja dann Figuren, die wahrscheinlich irgendwo auch copyrighted, urheberrechtlich geschützt oder was auch immer sind. Ist das ein großes Problem? Also hätte man das, dass Fans dann irgendwie aufs Maul bekommen?
Ja, es ist in der Tat ein Problem und es gibt tatsächlich Figuren und Geschichten, die sehr, sehr, also die verfolgen ihre Fans extrem, die Macher, die Produzenten. Ich weiß, dass bei Harry Potter ist das teilweise ein Problem, wenn es da um Slashfiction geht und es gibt auch andere Communities, die tatsächlich echt zu kämpfen haben mit ihren, mit den Produzenten. Es gibt andere, die sagen, sie finden das gut und sie wollen das und sie mögen den Austausch mit der Fangemeinde und diese ganzen Joss Whedon-Fandoms gehören dazu. Dem ist das glaube ich total wurscht.
Ursprünglich Buffy und dann Firefly.
Oder irgendwie Dr. Horrible.
Dr. Horrible, Singalong Block und Dollhouse. Und jetzt neuerdings The Avengers. Ja, Dollhouse war dann... Es war der kleine Ausgang.
Leute, worüber haltet ihr euch gerade?
Die Geschichte ist halt, also Firefly ist halt so ungefähr der Kult, der Prototyp einer Kult-Serie, Star Trek-Kult-Serie.
Science-Fiction-Kult-Serie.
Das ist eine Science-Fiction-Kult-Serie.
Science-Fiction-Kult.
Das bedeutet, die sind im Weltall mit Raumschiffen und Pistolen und Pferden.
Genau, also die Pferde sind eher selten im Weltraum, aber ja. Die haben manchmal Kühe in ihrem Laderaum, das stimmt schon.
Kühe haben sie in ihrem Raumschiff, genau. Also es geht darum, dass es einen Krieg gab und der Captain Reynolds war auf der falschen Seite sozusagen. Er hat verloren, er war auf der Seite der Rebellen. Jetzt ist das ganze Universum, das bekannte irgendwie ein Corporate-Universum und es ist alles nur glatt und gelackmeiert und so weiter und er passt da nicht mehr so richtig rein. Und dann hat er sich so eine Crew gesucht aus irgendwie so auch irgendwie Losern oder Außenseitern und fährt halt im Weltraum so an den Rändern des bekannten Weltraums rum und versucht irgendwie mit mehr oder weniger legalen oder illegalen Geschichten zu überleben.
Das ist schon aber eine super Projektionsfläche für eine Art, oder?
Ja, der Kampf gegen das Imperium. Es ist tatsächlich das Universum, das so aufgebaut ist, ein Sonnensystem mit vielen bewohnbaren Planeten ist und in der Mitte sind mehr so die hochglanzpolierten und am Rand wird es dann sehr westerlich, sehr borderwissen schon.
Und das, sagen wir um den Bogen zurückzuschließen, das ist halt auch eine Serie von Joss Whedon gewesen?
Genau, und da hat er halt das Problem, die hat er damals auf Fox gebracht und Fox hat das sowas von ihm sandgesetzt, das ist quasi legendär. Also die haben es in einer falschen Reihenfolge gesendet, was nicht so gut war, weil Joss Whedon gerne Charakterentwicklung hat und wenn die dann auf Dinge referenzieren, die noch nicht passiert sind, kommt das wenig gut. Sie haben es dann irgendwie in einen ganz schlechten Slot gelegt und nach 13 folgen glaube ich gesendeten Folgen abgesetzt. Es ist auch zum Einsteigen oder zum Gucken eine sehr schöne Serie, weil sie sehr kurz ist. Das ist der Vorteil, der Nachteil ist halt, dass sie sehr kurz ist.
Aber wir wollten noch eigentlich über Dollhouse und wir müssen auch gleich da hin.
Genau und der Punkt war dann mit Dollhouse, dass Joss Whedon dann mit Fox nochmal zusammengearbeitet hat, nachdem Fox ihm versprochen hat, dass sie die Serie nicht gleich mitten in der ersten Staffel absetzen. Aber die ist halt leider nicht so gut. Das ist okay, aber nicht großartig, nicht so wie viele andere Dinge.
Okay und bei da gibt es sozusagen also A viel Anlass zur Fanfiction und B ist sozusagen eher da nicht so hinterher, dass er den Leuten aufs Maul haut, wenn sie mit seinen Charakteren was machen.
Total nicht. Eines der Dinge, es gab ja vor, jetzt muss ich schon wieder, fünf Jahren, vier Jahren, in Amerika den Streik der Writers Guild, wo also die ganzen Film-Fernsehschreiber gestreikt haben. Und das gab also dann quasi so eine gezwungene Auszeit. Und in der Zeit hat er zusammen mit seinen Freunden quasi selbstfinanziert ein Webmusical geschrieben. Das war Dr. Horrible's Singalong-Blog. So als Videoblog aufgemacht, wo also der Dr. Horrible, ein gescheiterter Superbösewicht oder ein mächtiger Superbösewicht, zu Hause vor seiner Kamera, vor seiner Webcam sitzt und sein Videoblog aufnimmt und zwischendurch immer wieder Gesangseinlagen hat. Genau, Joss wollte ja schon immer gerne Musicals machen.
Es gibt ja auch immer irgendwie musikalische Einlagen in all seinen...
Genau, und Buffy hat da ein großartiges drin. Und Dr. Horrible ist halt ein komplettes Musical. Das sind drei Folgen zu je 10, 15 Minuten.
Was hat das mit Fans zu tun? Hat er mit Fans zusammengearbeitet oder?
Auch, also aufgenommen hat er das wohl sogar in einem Gebäude, in einem Haus, was er sich halt von jemandem geliehen hat, der da halt das toll fand und nur so als Dank am Ende in einer der Szenen auftaucht. Und das ist halt auch im Internet ein sehr großes Phänomen geworden. Und zwar deswegen besonders, weil er es halt komplett selbst finanziert, selbst vermarktet hat und danach sich dann doch selbst getragen hat.
Das ist deswegen auch für die Fan-Kultur ganz interessant, weil es sich eben genau nur durch diese Fan-Kultur, die um diesen Joss Whedon herum sehr lebendig ist, getragen hat. Also er hat halt einfach gesagt, kommt Leute, bezahlt den Scheiß einfach und dann haben die das gemacht.
Okay, ein kleiner Ausblick in die große Welt der Fan-Fiction. Da haben wir es in der ersten halben Stunde genommen. Wir werden uns gleich einer besonderen Form des Fantums widmen. Und Fantum hat ja manchmal auch sozusagen so ein bisschen, naja nicht anrüchigen, aber so den Ruf seltsam zu sein auch, also gerade Slashfiction wird mit hochgezogener Augenbrauer gerne betrachtet. Slashfiction ist nochmal die romantische Verknüpfung zweier Charaktere, die in der Originalhandlung nichts miteinander zu tun haben. Und dann gibt es jetzt aber so eine Fernsehserie, die ist an sich schon total absurd. Welche das ist, klären wir gleich. Erstmal machen wir das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr.
Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Sie war nicht wirklich clean.
Herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio in Blumenaufritzen. Sehr schön.
Das war jetzt, also ich muss das nochmal kontextualisieren, das war jetzt Kapitel 1 von The Party Hasn't Ended, einer Fanfiction-Geschichte von Butterscotch Sunday. Eine vermutlich Autorin von einer Fanfiction-Geschichte über My Little Pony. Friendship is Magic.
Und damit sind wir herzlich willkommen mitten im Chaosradio im Blue Moon, wo es heute um eine kulturelle Ausprägung des Nörrtums geht, sogenannte Fanfiction. Und das wollen wir ein bisschen näher am Beispiel beleuchten, einer Serie, wo es eigentlich gar keine Fanfiction braucht, bevor man die Augenbrauen hochsieht und sagt, was zur Hölle treibt ihr da? Und es geht halt genau um dieses My Little Pony, Friendship is Magic. Möglicherweise ist euch das schon mal im Netz begegnet, weil einige Leute lustige Bilder zu posten, andere Leute haben das auf Twitter als Avatar. So kleine Pferde, meistens blau Farben mit wilden Haarfrisuren.
Also vor allen Dingen sehr bunt. Das kann man eigentlich nicht übersehen. So fast Neonfarben, sehr stark saturierte Primärfarben.
Also wenn ihr schon mal blieb geworden seid von einem Icon, dann war es wahrscheinlich My Little Pony. So und jetzt kommen wir auch zu der Aufgabe, weswegen Henrik heute eigentlich hier ist. So erklär doch mal bitte für jemand, der noch nichts aus einem einzigen blauen Pferd gesehen hat. Was zur Hölle passiert hat?
Also was zur Hölle passiert ist ja eine Fernsehserie, wie viele andere auch, eine Kinderserie mit Figuren. Ursprünglich kam das aus grauer Vorzeit. Hasbro, eine Firma, ein Hersteller von kleinen Plastikspielfiguren in den 80ern, hatte eine Serie, die na My Little Pony war, also kleine Pferde für eine weibliche junge Kundschaft, Zielgruppe, mit langem Haar, sehr bunt. Es gibt da unglaublich viele. Ich hab es neulich zum ersten Mal in großer Zahl im Netz gesehen. Es gibt da also deutlich mehr Varianten von, als ich vorher dachte. Es gibt tatsächlich ein Wiki mit einer hoffentlichen vollständigen Liste. Ich will jetzt nicht Tausende sagen, aber deutlich mehr als mehrere hundert bis tausend, die da aufgelistet sind. Da gab es dann schon mal eine Fernsehserie in den 80ern, glaube ich, oder zumindest früher.
Damals, als wir nur Nullen und keine Einsen hatten.
Genau, als wir alle noch klein waren. Wir sind ja auch schon ein bisschen alt. Psst, das sieht man ja auch nicht.
Ich hatte kleine Ponys als Kind, ja, My Little Pony. Also es gibt schon echt lange.
Genau, aber es gibt halt auch eine neue Fernsehserie seit so 2010, wie die heutzutage mehr so der Stil ist, so computergeneriert, zweidimensional, wie gesagt, sehr stark gesättigte bunte Farben, die aus unklaren Gründen zu einer große Fangemeinde vor allen Dingen im Internet angesammelt hat. Und aus noch viel unklaren Gründen besteht diese Gemeinde hauptsächlich aus Männern über 20.
So, das ist jetzt, also du sagst jetzt unklar. Das mag jetzt für die Allgemeinheit, dann könnte man es einfach stehen lassen, jetzt bist du aber selber einer davon. Also du bist sozusagen ein über 20 Jahre alter Mann, der sich zum Beispiel auch mit so fiesen Dingen wie, wo warst du noch mal dabei? E-Card, Personalausweis, irgendwie so. Also ein ernst zu nehmender Hacker, der auch schon in der Öffentlichkeit aufgetreten ist, wo man jetzt sagen würde, ok, blaue Zeichentrickpferde sind nicht das Erste, was man dazu einfällt. Was ist für dich persönlich die Faszination an diesem Ding?
Persönlich? Also ich mag die Serie, ich guck sie gerne. Jede Staffel ist jetzt gerade zu Ende, sonst jeden Sonntag. Es ist einfach fröhlich, einfach was anderes, eine Ablenkung. Und es verbreitet quasi Freude, wenn man es auch nur anguckt. Also es ist nicht für jeden, es ist eine sehr stark polarisierende Sache, wenn ich das mal so formulieren darf. Es gibt da im Internet auf YouTube ein wunderschönes Video, da gibt es so eine Serie Teens React To und da hat man es halt zusammengeschnitten, so zehn Minuten lang ungefähr. So hat man so fünf oder zehn Teenager zusammengesucht und zeigt denen irgendwas und filmt dann die Reaktionen. Dann gibt es halt eine Folge mit Teens React To, My Little Pony. Und da sieht man das auch schon, was mir auch persönlich begegnet ist, dass die Reaktionen entweder total toll oder sowas von Scheiße sind. Es gibt da nicht sehr viel Raum dazwischen. Man findet es entweder toll oder man hasst es.
Also ich habe tatsächlich überlegt, ob ich jetzt mir in Vorbereitung dieser Sendung dieses Ding mal komplett reinziehe, dachte aber so nein, ich möchte lieber unbefleckt, möchte ich an dieser Stelle fast sagen, in diese Sendung gehen. Es ist natürlich in der Vorbereitung nicht ganz vermeiden und ich muss schon sagen Alter Schwede.
Ja also das höre ich auch, also von anderen Leuten im Chaos-Umfeld kommen dann so Formulierungen, also wenn man ihnen mal ein Bild gezeigt hat oder verlinkt hat und sie haben drauf geklickt, dass sie sich jetzt die Augen mit Bleiche auswaschen müssen, um das wieder wegzukriegen oder dass man schon vom angucken Diabetes kriegt, dass so zuckersüß alles ist.
Aber es gibt ja auch noch, also es gibt ja die ironische Sichtweise darauf und die tatsächlich unironische, also das was du jetzt beschreibst ist sozusagen die Sichtweise oder die Perspektive, die auch das eigentliche Zielpublikum der Serie, nämlich sechsjährige Mädchen, haben. Also die gucken das und sehen das tatsächlich ganz wörtlich. Mit Freundschaft ist Magie und wir müssen uns alle lieb haben und loyal zueinander sein und lachen und so was halt da irgendwie so. Die Werte sind die da vermittelt werden. Das ist ja nur eine Perspektive auf dieses Phänomen und ich denke mal es gibt auch nochmal andere Ebene darauf. Also ansonsten...
Dieses ironische, ja das...
Ich habe jetzt auch in der Vorbereitung dieser Sendung zwei Folgen gesehen. Das ist schon sehr simpel gestrickt.
Also wir haben ja im Rahmen der Vorbereitung auch über andere Serien gesprochen. Da hieß es ja, genau so, also irgendwie bei Star Trek oder Babylon 5 oder so, da wird irgendwie Folter verdeckt sozusagen in der Geschichte verpackt oder wie man mit Leuten halt umgeht, gesellschaftliche Probleme werden irgendwie kommuniziert. Es ist aber nicht so, dass das auch im Little Pony drin steckt?
Doch, doch, natürlich, während in Next Generation, da werden ja auch immer Konflikte einvernehmlich gelöst und durch Reden und so. Das ist schon auch sehr flauschig eigentlich. Nur bei My Little Pony wird das Ganze nochmal runtergebrochen auf eine Verständnis-Ebene für Kinder. Also da geht es um sehr, sehr einfache westliche, einfachen westlichen Wertekanon. Das haben ja viele Fernsehserien, vor allen Dingen Fernsehserien für Kinder, dass es da einfache Lösungen gibt. Es gibt das Gute, es gibt das Böse, das Gute ist gut, das Böse ist böse. Wenn man sich jetzt mal Serien vielleicht nicht so aus dem westlichen Kulturraum anguckt, da ist das Ganze ein bisschen graustufiger. Das heißt also ein bisschen, da ist das Böse nicht immer nur böse. Und das Gute nicht immer nur gut. Also da gibt es komplexere Figuren. Und My Little Pony hat jetzt nicht unbedingt die mega komplexen Figuren, würde ich sagen.
Ja, das ist schon sehr glatt gemacht. Also in der zweiten Staffel zumindest sind die Beweggründe nicht notwendigerweise böse und gut, sondern der Hauptgegenspieler ist der Discord, der einfach nur Chaos überall sehen möchte.
Der Übrigen ist der gleiche, also der Sprecher ist der Mensch, der Q bei Star Trek Next Planet gibt.
Genau, ich hätte jetzt hier einen Soundboard gehabt, ich könnte es anspielen, man hört es in der Stimme sehr schön. Die Figur ist ja auch sehr ähnlich, so ein Schelm, der Dinge mit magischen Kräften quasi verhext und lustige Dinge macht.
Und dann bringen wir noch mal das Dialogbeispiel, worum es in My Little Pony, was da so die Moral der Geschichte ist, das finde ich auch schön.
Also tatsächlich, wir hatten das vorbereitet, wir haben am Ende der ersten Doppelfolge geht es halt darum, dass das Böse, in dem Fall repräsentiert durch Nightmare Moon, zu besiegen ist mit den Elementen der Harmonie, die Elements of Harmonie und das zumindest an der Stelle, wo wir gleich einsteigen, in der es ja nicht so geklappt zu haben scheint, man muss dazu sagen, es gibt, vielleicht kurz die Figuren erklären, es gibt sechs Hauptfiguren, die sogenannten Main Six, Main in dem Fall M-A-N-E geschrieben. Genau, es sind also in der Tat...
Also ich glaube tatsächlich, wenn man jetzt die sechs Charaktere noch mal einzelnen auseinanderklamüset, das wird...
Also das ist das Wichtigste, das was wir gerade gleich hören werden, ist Twilight Sparkle, das ist so mehr oder weniger die Hauptfigur der Serie und sie hat halt fünf Freunde gefunden in diesen ersten beiden Folgen und darum geht es.
Fluttershy, who tamed the Manticore with her compassion, represents the spirit of kindness. Pinkie Pie, who banished fear by giggling in the face of danger, represents the spirit of laughter.
Ja, also jetzt wo du es sagst, das klingt schon so ein bisschen Captain Planet mäßig, das gebe ich zu.
Es ist eine einfache Moral und Diägese, die dahintersteckt. Also das ist sozusagen das Universum der Ponys ist recht simpel, aber schön in dieser Einfachheit. Also diese Elemente der Harmonie und das, was tatsächlich einen guten Menschen ausmacht, das ist ja sozusagen Moralschule der ersten Güte. Loyalität und Ehrlichkeit.
Ich frage mich gerade, ob der Nerd an sich, der sich ja immer in so ein Thema total rein vertieft, das heißt oft, also gerade auch im Computerbereich, Programmiersprachen, Hardwerkerei, mit super komplexen Welten zu tun hat, ob das einfach so eine Art Gegenprogramm ist. Das ist halt flach, das ist total süß, das ist total primärfarbig.
Ich glaube, da sind jetzt gerade sehr viele Leute, die hier widersprechen würden, wenn du sagst, es ist flach.
Ja bitte, 0331 70 97 110.
Ein kleines Beispiel, wie das mit dem Reinvertiefen ist. Es gibt eine Figur, die drin vorkommt, die man in der ersten Folge nur ganz kurz sieht. Das ist eigentlich ein Zeichenfehler gewesen. Das ist in der ersten Folge so für eine Drittelsekunde im Bild, so wenn man ein Standbild macht, so drei Bilder lang oder so. Im Hintergrund ist ein Pony mit verdrehten Augen. Das hat allerdings irgendjemand gesehen, hat ein Standbild davon gemacht und ist dann im Internet rumgegangen. Die Fans haben das Pony Derpy Hooves genannt und fanden das total toll. Es gibt sehr viel Fanfiction dazu. Ich hab's dann auch als ich gesehen habe, wollte ich die Stelle finden und ich hab sie halt viermal überspielt, bevor ich sie gefunden habe, obwohl ich genau wusste, wo ich gucken muss. Und die Macher haben das dann mitgekriegt. Also es gibt da so einen Austausch tatsächlich und haben dieses Pony dann später tatsächlich offiziell integriert. Und das kommt in einer Folge sogar mit einer längeren Sprechrolle vor, mit den verdrehten Augen. Das war halt ursprünglich ein Zeichenfehler.
Unglaublich. So, jetzt seid ihr beide, habt schon darüber gesprochen. Jetzt haben tatsächlich auch ein paar Anrufe angerufen. Schon vorhin, als wir noch ganz allgemein gesprochen haben über Fanfiction und Phantom und Atelier, haben alle für Ponys angerufen. Ihr könnt das gerne auch noch tun.
Das ist was anderes. Jetzt anrufen!
0331 70 97 110 So, der erste ist dann ein gewisser Herr jetzt. Hallo und guten Tag. Herr jetzt rauscht ganz schön.
Ich rausche ganz schön. Es kann sein, dass ich über dieses Voip-Anrufe, was über das Internet geht.
Okay, das hat doch schon mal nicht funktioniert in dieser Sendung.
Ah, Raketentechnologie.
Raketentechnologie.
Gut, du und die Ponys, wie passt das zusammen? Hast du eigentlich Ponys oder Ponys?
Das kommt, glaube ich, darauf an, in welcher Sprache man die Sendung guckt. Ich guck's auf Englisch und da heißt es Ponys.
Ich glaube, niemand guckt das auf Deutsch.
Ich hab da so eine Talkshow gesehen, wo es mal auf Deutsch eingespielt wurde.
Genau, und anschließend, also Herr Urbach, der dann in der Talkshow war, hat er dann auch einen sehr verdatterten Gesichtsausdruck, das zum ersten Mal auf Deutsch gehört hat.
Das war sehr gruselig, ja.
Okay, man guckt es also auf Englisch. Wie bist du zu dieser Serie gekommen?
Über das Internet. Also ich glaube, die Ponys haben angefangen als ein Mem, also quasi ein Element der Kultur, der Netzkultur, was sich da irgendwann mal so gebildet hat und was dann einfach da war. Dazu muss ich jetzt aber auch nicht viel mehr sagen, weil es gibt dazu CRE 112.
Du bist jetzt beim Chaosradio und du musst doch was dazu sagen. Du musst es nämlich genau erklären.
Ich muss Meme erklären. Also Meme sind einfach Elemente der Netzkultur, wo ein Element so aus der Welt genommen wird und massiv verbreitet wird, resampled wird, wo immer quasi dasselbe Thema in vielen Interaktionen abgewandelt wird und was sich dann quasi zum kulturellen Selbstläufer entwickelt. Also ein Beispiel dafür ist zum Beispiel auch, sagen wir mal, dieses Exhibit-Meme, wo Exhibit sagt, er hört, du möchtest Auto, also leg dir ein Auto an, du möchtest Auto, du kannst also fahren, weil du fährst. Das hat sich irgendwann verselbstständig und hat dieses einfach Mark-Kurve da genommen und wurden immer wieder neue Satzbausteine eingefügt. Und so ist das halt mit vielen Sachen und eben auch mit Ponys.
Also vielleicht zur Erklärung, Meme, der Begriff kommt von Richard Dawkins in seinem Buch. Der ist eigentlich Evolutions- oder er ist Biologe und sehr stark in der Evolutionstheorisszene bzw. als Gegenpol in Amerika ist das ja mit Evolution und Kreationismus so ein bisschen. Deswegen muss er da einen starken Gegenpol bieten. Und er hat in einem seiner ersten Bücher halt den Begriff Meme geprägt, M-E-M-E, als Analogon zu Gen. Und der spricht dort halt darüber, dass Memen von Memetisch sind Informationseinheiten, die sich quasi selbst verbreiten, so wie sie oder ja genau bei denen es um die Verbreitung geht, die sich also nach darwinistischen Prinzipien verbreiten und wachsen bzw. wieder eingehen und ähnlich wie halt Gene sich verbreiten.
Selbstständig gewordene Ideen, die durchs Internet fliegen, könnte man sagen.
Also nicht nur durchs Internet, halt durch die gesamte Kultur, die sich als Menschen mit Menschen als Träger verbreiten.
Aber die man sozusagen aus dem Netz vor allem kennt, als irgendwie, man nimmt ein Bild irgendwo und macht da noch Schrift drauf und bastelt sozusagen eine Idee oder ein Scherz.
Genau, das ist die verflachte neue Definition von Meme.
Also Meme kann man auch nicht sagen, ohne das Imageport Fortune zu erwähnen, wo irgendwie ganz viele Meme auch herkommen.
Dazu muss man vielleicht sagen, dass der Gründer bzw. der Betreiber von Fortune auch meinte, also Mut meinte, Slash B ist, wo Meme gehen, um zu sterben.
Ja, das hat er sich aber bei den Ponys angeht ziemlich verschätzt, weil die Ponys das erste Meme waren, was Fortune kaputt gemacht hat und wo diese ganzen Leute, die in diesem Fortune-Image-Sport rumhängen, festgestellt haben, dass sie selber damit nicht klarkommen. Also die Ponys sind ein sehr, sehr Discord-geplägtes, spaltendes Phänomen.
Es tut mir leid, dass ich es schon wieder unterbrechen muss, aber jetzt noch eine Pause. Fortune ist ein Board im Netz, wo Leute Bilder posten, die dann auch nach einiger Zeit wieder verschwinden, wo es sehr hart zugeht, also wo man nicht mit einer dünnen Haut unterwegs sein kann. Wenn ich richtig informiert bin, ist das mit den Ponys so gewesen, dass das das erste Mal gewesen ist, dass es ein Meme gab, was gegen den Willen der Moderatoren dort durchgedrückt wurde, und zwar so lange, bis sie einen eigenen Kanal bekommen haben. So, und da bist du auch draufgekommen? Nein.
Ich hab das dann irgendwann im Zuge der Netzkultur mitbekommen, dass es das gibt. Man kommt ja eigentlich auch nicht dann vorbei, im Netz über Ponys zu stolpern. Ich hab die Ponys auf allen möglichen Sachen mitbekommen. Zum Beispiel lief auf dem letzten Chaos Communication Congress über irgendeinen Screen, der da wohl gekapert wurde, Ponys-Content. Ich hab so richtig keinen Lieblingspony. Ich hab mal einen Pony-Selbsttest gemacht und da war ich Ding Sie hier. Ja, genau.
Fantastisch, ein tolles Pony. Was hat das für einen Cutie-Mark?
Was machst du wie der Begriffe auf?
Tina, du hast gewonnen. Was ist ein Cutie-Mark?
Das Cutie-Mark ist das Zeichen, dass jedes Pony auf der rechten Hinterflanke, oder auf beiden vielleicht?
Auf beiden.
Auf beiden. Also auf den Hinterflanken sozusagen, auf dem Pony-Po. Und das ist das Zeichen, was es so besonders macht.
Also genau, entweder was es besonders kann, was so eine Art Bestimmung Cutie-Marks kriegen, das wird in der Serie erklärt, Ponys im Laufe ihres Erwachsenwerdens, so wie quasi Pubertät erwachsen werden, mehr oder weniger, ein bisschen früher, noch in der Schule. Und genau, es zeigt halt irgendwie an, was es besonders kann, was es besonders gut findet. Und es gibt einige Episoden. Es gibt nämlich drei Ponys, um die es geht. Die haben keinen Cutie-Mark. Es gibt dann den derogativen Begriff Blank Flanks. Die haben also blanke Hintern. Und die anderen necken sie deswegen. Und die versuchen halt die ganze Zeit herauszufinden, was sie besonders macht, was dann ihr... Sie wollen ihr Cutie-Mark kriegen und wollen das irgendwie erzwingen. Die anderen sagen, man kann das nichts echt nicht erzwingen, aber genau.
Ist das auch wieder eine dieser ganz klassischen Kalenderspruchweisheiten? So finde ich deine Bestimmung.
Genau, und du kannst es nicht erzwingen. Sie versuchen halt in verschiedenen Plots das irgendwie zu erzwingen, mit Magie oder sonst was. Und das geht halt natürlich immer kalasistrophal schief.
Großartig. So, jetzt musst du sagen, über diese Serie gestolpert hast auch einen Lieblings-Ding-Z-Pony. Was ist denn jetzt genau, was glaubst du, was hat diese Serie mit dem Nerd-Tumor? Was ist die Verbindung dazwischen?
Die Verbindung ist ganz klar. Einerseits ist so in der Netzkultur, in der Hacker-Kultur sowieso stark vorhanden, dass irgendwie Fanfiction und Memes eine wichtige Rolle spielen. Also ob ich jetzt alle Galaxy-Klasse Starships aufzählen kann oder Klingonisch lerne oder eben die Ponys gucke, läuft im Prinzip auf einer ähnlichen Schiene. Allerdings ist es mehr so die junge Generation von Leuten, die sich da im Internet verortet, die diese Ponys jetzt irgendwie toll findet und dass sie zu ihrem Memenerkoren hat. Ich glaube, ich sehe da auch einen Konflikt, dass einige Menschen diese Ponys nicht haben wollen. Also zum Beispiel wird es auf der Second einen Talk zu Ponys geben und der hat im Profil schon für ganz viel Discord gesorgt.
Ja, vielleicht der Kontext dazu ist, dass diese Ponys oder überhaupt diese ganzen Meme-Sachen relativ weit in eine Kultur reingehen, die muss man erklären. Also Leute, denen man irgendwie Pony-Content zeigt, die sind erstmal verdattert, verwirrt. Das ist auch eher unverständlich. Weil das ist auch ein sehr nicht zugängliches Konstrukt, diese Serie. Also wenn man sich das so anguckt und das tatsächlich nicht ironisch sieht, dann ist das eher verwirrend. Wenn man jetzt weiß, das sind jetzt 20-jährige Männer, die sich das angucken.
Ja klar, es gibt ja so einerseits das Selbstbild der harten Hacker, die irgendwie ihren Code noch irgendwie mit zueinanderhaltenden Kabeln eingeben. Und das kratzt natürlich so ein bisschen an dem Selbstbild als Hacker, diese pinken, bunten, fluffigen Ponys zu sehen.
Ich möchte heute tatsächlich sagen, sollten diesem Chaosradio nicht um die Leute gehen, die das nicht mögen, sondern um die anderen.
Genau, das hat ich ja vorhin schon gesagt. Es gibt halt immer eine sehr stark polarisierende Sache.
Ja, darauf wollte ich auch hinaus. Auf der anderen Seite sind halt die Ponys einfach so ein seelischer Schokoladending, der einfach irgendwie hilft, mit der harten Realität umzugehen und auch eine schöne Welt, die irgendwie super harmonisch ist, wo Freundschaft eine wichtige Rolle spielt, wo es immer irgendwie eine klare Moral gibt und die einem einfach hilft, irgendwie mit der harten Realität klarzukommen. Das sind im Prinzip die, da auch frohes hinauslaufen. Weshalb ich glaube, dass die Ponys auch so unglaublich populär sind unter den Nerds oder in der Netzkultur.
Also es gibt da auch einen ganz großen Aspekt des Haters gonna hate. Ihr findet es doof, dass wir das toll finden, dann finden wir das jetzt noch viel toller und in your face. Mal gucken, wer so was in der Art ist. Also extra deswegen eine Reaktanzreaktion.
Das wird also sagen, auch benutzt, einfach um sich zu präsentieren. Also so wie man sich, keine Ahnung, der Vergleich ist vielleicht ein bisschen weitergeholt, aber sozusagen, wie sich früher die Punks die Haare bunt gefärbt haben. Weil damit fällt man auf und ist sozusagen...
Natürlich. Ponys sind ganz klar auch ein identitärer Bestandteil von Kultur.
Ist das denn für dich sozusagen... Du hast jetzt diese Folgen gesehen, um zu gucken, worum es da ging. Und ist das für dich jetzt sozusagen die wichtigere Seite, diese Identifikationsding? Oder wirst du auch tatsächlich die Serie weitergucken?
Ich muss ehrlich gesagt... Ich habe irgendwie, glaube ich, drei Folgen bisher geguckt und die Handlungsbögen haben mich noch nicht so erreicht. Aber andererseits für dieses seelische Wohlbefinden, dieser, wie ich schon sagte, dieser seelische Schokoladensägen. Der gibt mir sehr, sehr viel. Und mich da auch irgendwie so in der Flauschinggruppe der Leute, die diese Ponys toll finden, irgendwie einzufinden und da einfach bei diesem Wohlfühl, bei diesem Wohlbefindensding mitzumachen, das ist einfach das, was mir gerade besonders viel gibt, wo für mich gerade besonders viel Spaß rausfällt und weswegen ich das auf jeden Fall weiterbezeigen werde.
Also was man auch noch sagen muss, also nicht nur die Handlungsbögen, auch die Musik ist ja sehr gut und sehr mitreißend und sehr ohrwürmerzeugend. Es gibt denn nicht jeder Folge, aber in vielen Folgen starke musikalische Einlagen, die sehr zum Mitsingen einladen und einem auch nicht mehr so leicht aus dem Kopf gehen.
Gut, also wenn ihr möglicherweise da schon textsicher seid, könnt ihr das gerne mal ausprobieren. Wir präsentieren euch jetzt nämlich einen Song. Das ist diese unglaubliche Serie, einen kurzen.
Okay, dann kommt jetzt wahrscheinlich das Intro.
Nein, den Ghosty Song.
Ach so, okay, ja, das ist natürlich auch gut. Man muss dazusagen, die Situation, die sind jetzt in einem Wald und da sind ganz viele Bäume, die nach gefährlichen Schattengeistern und so weiter aussehen. Und eine Figur Pinkie Pie, die ihres Zeichens für Partys und Spaß zuständig ist, fängt jetzt also an diesen Bäumen auf ihre eigene Art zu begegnen.
Ponys, herzlich willkommen im Chaosradio im Blue Moon auf Fritz, wo es heute um einen Teil der Nerdkultur geht, der sich auf, ja also es geht um Fanfiction im Groberen und im Speziellen erklären wird das heute anscheinend an einer Serie, die, wie heißt das komplett, Henrik? Henrik ist nämlich der Pony-Experte hier im Studio und am Telefon haben wir eine Expertin noch, sozusagen heute ganze Zeit auch in der Sendung, nämlich Tina.
Tina ist nur kein Pony-Experte. Tina ist ein bisschen mehr für die Slashfiction zuständig.
Okay, Slashfiction noch mal kurz erklärt, sag noch mal kurz in eigenen Worten bitte.
Slashfiction dreht sich um Geschichten, die romantische oder sexuelle Beziehungen zwischen zwei Figuren einer Serie, eines Buches thematisieren, die in dieser Serie oder in dem Buch im Original sozusagen, im Kanon, nicht diese romantischen oder sexuellen Beziehungen haben.
So kann es passieren. Gibt es sowas für My Little Pony auch? Das hört sich an wie, ja, aber ich möchte nicht drüber reden.
Also du musst halt auch immer in Betracht ziehen, dass Regel 34 da ist.
So ich kenne Regel 34, die Hörer nicht. Bitte, Henrik?
Regel 34 ist eigentlich sehr kurz und sehr prägnant. Wer ist Porn of it?
Also auf Deutsch genau, wenn es existiert, gibt es davon Pornos.
Genau, ich würde es vielleicht noch kürzer sagen, es gibt Pornos davon. Das ist halt in der Kürze sehr irreführend, denn die Implikationen davon sind natürlich sehr ausladend. Ja, es gibt dann tatsächlich auch extra, um Leute zu provozieren. Also bei manchen sieht man dann, dass es weniger um die sexuelle Erregung geht, als mehr darum, Leute explizit zu provozieren. Wenn man also sieht, wie Biene-Maja-Widdy einen bläst, dann ist das eigentlich nur deswegen da.
Okay, verstehe. Slashfiction, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, da geht es ja nicht nur um Porn, sondern da geht es ja auch um die romantische Beziehung. Gibt es sowas dann auch?
Ja, aber es inkludiert irgendwo immer ein sexuelles Element. Also es ist eine Sexualisierung von Beziehungen, die im Kranon nicht sexualisiert sind oder nur sehr subtil sexualisiert sind. Und bei My Little Pony, da ist überhaupt nicht sexualisiert. Die Zielgruppe sind sechsjährige Mädchen, da geht es überhaupt nicht um Romantik und Liebe und Sex. Allerdings ist es so, dass bei My Little Pony ist die Slashfiction eher, wie soll ich sagen, also nicht ganz so ausufernd. Also wenn es Slashfiction gibt, dann ist es meistens, ein Mensch kommt nach Equestria, Equestria ist das Universum da, also die Welt, in der diese Ponys leben. Das gibt es in der Tat, aber was ich viel, viel mehr gefunden habe, ist Fanfiction, also Geschichten über diese Ponys mit diesen Ponys, mit diesen kanonischen Figuren und die dann weiter oder in alternativen Universen, die die Handlung sozusagen ein bisschen weiter treiben.
Okay, davon gibt es eine große Fangemeinde von diesen kleinen Ponys und Daniel ist anscheinend der Leiter einer solche Fangemeinde. Hallo Daniel. 1200 Leute? Hast du auf deiner Seite vermutlich versammelt?
Die hören alle zu, richtig.
Um Gottes Willen!
Ihr glaubt gar nicht, wie viel, wahrscheinlich auch weltweit gerade den Livestream im Internet mithören.
Aber dann erklär du doch mal, was für dich die Faszination an dieser Serie ist.
Die Faszination an der Serie ist für mich erstmal die ganze Fangemeinde dahinter. Denn ich glaube, ich hab noch nie im Internet, man kennt ja verschiedene Fangemeinden von, egal ob jetzt ganzen Zeichensstilen wie Anime, Manga, diese ganze Animax-Geschichte, die Cosplayer und so. Egal was man sieht im Internet, es existiert irgendwo immer so ein Wettbewerb, wer da der Beste ist und wer besser ist als der andere, wer das schönste Cosplay, also Kostüm hat. Cosplay, schätze ich, muss ich nicht erklären, oder?
Na ja, man könnte kurz sagen, das sind Leute, die sich anziehen, also wirklich so kostümieren und auch basteln, um genauso auszusehen, wie die Leute aus den Serienbüchern oder was auch immer.
Und das existiert zum Beispiel bei, es gibt, erstmal wollte ich erklären, was diese Fans der Serie My Little Pony nennen sich Bronies.
Stimmt, das hatte ich ganz vergessen.
Genau, ein Kofferwort aus Bro, also Brother, Bruder und Pony hat es auch auf Fortschreit entstanden, soweit ich informiert bin. Und in dieser Brony-Community, bei den Musikern zum Beispiel, gibt es absolut keinen Wettbewerb, wer der Beste ist. Die arbeiten alle zusammen, egal woher sie kommen. Es ist international, es ist völlig wurscht, woher man kommt, egal ob, ich weiß nicht, Australien, Deutschland, Italien, USA. Man arbeitet immer zusammen, man tauscht sich aus mit irgendwelchen Informationen. Egal Musik, Zeichnungen, es gibt auf DeviantArt unendlich viele Brony-Gruppen mit begnadeten Künstlern, die sich da wirklich ins Volk legen. Nach einer Episode, da ist ein neues Pony aufgetaucht, jetzt erst vor kurzem die letzte Folge. Da ist ein neues Pony aufgetaucht und es gibt innerhalb von zwei Stunden Bilder, die könnten, weiß ich nicht, für 1000 Euro verkauft werden, weil sie so wunderschön sind und die werden in zwei Stunden gezeichnet, superschnell und superschön. Und dass da einfach wirklich Leute sind, die wirklich was drauf haben, ein Riesentalent und völlig freundlich sind. Es gibt nicht keines, ich hab selten erlebt, dass es irgendwie was gibt, wie aus anderen Communities kennt man ja.
Das heißt aber, der Hauptreiz besteht für dich eigentlich nicht so sehr in der Serie, sondern eher in der Leute, die sich dahinter sozialisiert haben.
In der Serie auf jeden Fall, ich glaube, ich hab jede Folge viel zu oft gesehen. Ich würde sagen, man kann sie nicht zu oft sehen, aber ich hab jede Folge bestimmt mindestens zehnmal geschaut. Ich liebe diese Serie, es ist unfassbar. Es macht einfach glücklich, die zu sehen. Wie soweit ich weiß, Herr Urbach ja gesagt hat, es macht einfach happy.
Es macht einfach glücklich.
Es ist einfach schön, die Serie zu sehen. Da ist ja auch so ein gewisser Witz drin, den eben kleine Kinder vielleicht gar nicht verstehen. Das sieht man ja auch bei anderen Serien.
Es ist tatsächlich, es sind Elemente eingebaut, die irgendwie keiner versteht, die man selbst als Erwachsener erst nachschlagen muss zumindest. Ich hatte das gerade erst gehört, in der letzten Folge sind wohl in der Musik irgendwie über musikalische Tricks Hinweise auf den Plot eingebaut. Der Macher der Musik, Daniel Ingram, wenn ich mich gerade nicht täusche, ist da sehr aktiv unterwegs. Es ist nicht ganz wie bei den Simpsons, was ja jetzt direkt keine Kinderserie ist, aber es ist schon ähnlich, dass tatsächlich dann mehrere Ebenen drin sind, die man auch als Erwachsener zu schätzen weiß.
Okay, Daniel sagt, Ponys sind zum Wohlfühlen total super. Daniel, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf und viel Spaß noch in der Fan-Community. So, ich bin ja ein bisschen erstaunt, dass beim Chaosradio heute echt die Leitungen voll sind. Das ist ja eher selten anscheinend. Gibt es da eine Übereinstimmung zwischen Nörrtum und Populärkultur? Oder ist es tatsächlich viel mehr?
Die Leute finden Ponys einfach prima.
Wir haben keine Hasse in der Leitung.
Und hoffen wir, dass das so bleibt. Aber wir haben ein paar Leute, die sagen, wo es nicht die Ponys sind, sondern die noch mal generell zur Fanfiction was sagen wollen. Zum Beispiel den Alex aus Lichtenberg. Sag mal kurz, worum geht es bei dir?
Und die anderen Adoptionen von den Leuten.
Was genau ist das?
Lord of the Weed ist eher nicht schlecht synchronisiert, aber doch sehr ins Licherliche gezogen und sehr, sehr lustig. Also wenn man auf wirklich platten Humor steht...
Ja, es ist tatsächlich ein sehr spezieller Geschmack. Ich konnte es nicht lustig finden.
Ja, keine Gemeinsamkeit. Aber die einfach wirklich nur berieseln lassen und sich den wirklich absoluten Bullshit da reinzuziehen. Und die Leute, die haben sich da wirklich Mühe gegeben, es wirklich auch sehr platt wirken zu lassen.
Du meinst, sie haben darum gekämpft, das Niveau auf ein neues Mindestmaß herabzusenken?
Absolut, absolut, nee, also wirklich jetzt der Wind pfeift durch die Bäume, wirklich alles so mit dem Mund.
Okay, sehr albern und sehr billig, was ist dann für dich der Reiz daran?
Ja, allein die Tatsache, dass sich die Leute damit auseinandergesetzt haben und versucht haben, da irgendwo nochmal eine völlig sinnlose Story eigentlich reinzubasteln. Und es hat auch sehr, sehr viele Anhänger, wie ich mitbekommen habe. Dadurch entstanden noch sehr viele Adaptionen, wie zu Star Trek und... Ja, bestes Beispiel ist hier...
Der war auf der Stitch, Buhl, Bäh...
Was war das gerade?
Ah, keine Ahnung, schieß mich durch.
Die hessische Fansynchro von Star Trek TNG, glaube ich. Meinst du das mit dem schwarzen Kaffee?
Echt, einen schwarzen Kaffee! Okay, ja, da gibt es in der Tat jede Menge Zeug. YouTube ist da, glaube ich, Ansprechpartner der Wahl.
Aber mit Ausrufezeichen absolut, ja.
Alex, hast du das selber schon mal an sowas versucht?
Ja, ganz ehrlich, ich meine, wer jetzt so sagt, der hat nicht irgendwie mal zu Hause da gesessen, irgendwie im Freundeskreis und hat mal ein DVD Play auf Mute geschaltet. Und hat sich da selber eine Story so ausgedacht, der lügt.
Aha, kleine Kostprobe gefällig? Okay, Alex, trotzdem vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Ja, gerne. So, Tina, wollte ich mal fragen, ist das denn, ich hätte jetzt vermutet, wenn es Fanfiction gibt, dass dann eigentlich die Leute sich Mühe geben, das so gut wie möglich zu machen, weil man dann so am Original dran ist. Aber sozusagen dieses, wir machen es total platt, weil wir es eh nicht können, ist das sozusagen ein Stilmittel?
Ja, man muss da so ein bisschen unterscheiden zwischen Fanfiction und Spoof. Also das, was der Alex auch gerade so ein bisschen erzählt hat, geht ein bisschen in die Richtung Spoof, denke ich mal. Da wird ein Original genommen und es wird verändert, es wird persifliert, es wird damit gespielt und es wird tatsächlich so ein bisschen durch den Kakao gezogen. Spoof findet man zum Beispiel auch in der Pornografie ganz, ganz vermehrt. Da werden irgendwie populär erfolgreiche Filme und Bücher genommen und durch so eine Pornomangel gedreht. Und Fanfiction ist aber tatsächlich sehr ernst gemeint. Also diese Fan-Community, die bezeichnen sich selber wirklich als Fans. Also die finden das gut, diesen Kanon und diese Welt dieser Figuren. Und die tauchen da so sehr drin ein und schreiben das halt weiter. Also das ist sehr ernsthaft gemeint.
Okay, das heißt du würdest dieses Spoof dann rausnehmen daraus?
Es gibt auch Fans-Boosts, also ich glaube, es war eine hessische, ich weiß nicht, ich habe den Dialekt nie so richtig zuordnen können. Aber es gibt ja diese deutsche Synchro von Star Trek Next Generation. Die ist auch sehr witzig, das ist auch fanbasiert und fangemacht, aber es geht nicht in Richtung Fanfiction, weil es die Stories nicht ernsthaft weiterentwickelt. Also es ist mehr so eine Persiflage.
Das sagst du jetzt, aber wer weiß, was sich für Bedeutungen dahinter verstecken. Ich meine selbst bunte Ponys, aber egal.
Siegerländerplatt lese ich gerade. Es ist Siegerländerplatt, sagt Philipp Stefan. Der muss es hoffentlich wissen.
Alles klar, wenn ihr noch selber ein Beispiel habt oder euch mal versucht habt und das mal hier zum Besten vorgehen wollt, gerne 0331 70 97 110. Wir kehren zurück zu den Ponys. Ludwig aus Bitburg. Hallo Ludwig. Was ist deine Faszination an den kleinen bunten Pferden?
Ach ja, was ist meine Faszination? Diese Ponys haben mein Leben zum Positiven verändert. Also ich, ja wie krieg ich es aus? Es war so, dass ich, ich bin jetzt seit ungefähr ein halbes oder Jahr in der Brony-Gemeinde und bin auch in der größten deutschen Brony-Gemeinde, wovor uns auch der Daniel schon angerufen hat. Und bin auch wirklich stolzes Mitglied davon. Und ja, ich bin halt aus mir selbst rausgekommen. Ich war früher, ich sag mal, ein bisschen in mich gekehrt. Ich hatte Angst auf andere Leute zuzugehen und war auch nicht wirklich selbstbewusst. Aber naja, nachdem ich dann halt angefangen hab, diese Ponys zu gucken, habe ich halt gemerkt, ich kann mich eigentlich so nehmen, wie ich bin. Durch diese ganzen Moralen, die am Ende der Folge gebracht werden, wie vorhin schon erwähnt wurde. Ja, und das macht mich halt richtig stolz, ein Teil davon zu sein.
Aber wir haben ja auch schon lange gehört, dass diese Moraldinger eher platt waren. Inwiefern...
Nein, nein, nein, nicht platt. Simple, hab ich gesagt. Das ist was anderes.
Okay, simpel.
Aber das heißt ja nicht weniger wahr, genau.
Ja, aber nur weil die simpel sind, heißt es ja nicht direkt, dass sie dadurch weniger gut sind. Das sagt doch wer. Weil die ganzen Fabeln alle, die haben ja auch eine simple Moralwende und trotzdem werden sie immer wieder Kindern als Beispiel erklärt.
Ja, sehr blutig bei Grim in der Tat.
Da sind die Ponys nicht ganz so blutig, zumindest nicht im Kanan.
Und das ist halt genau dasselbe, was ich dann halt so sehe. Diese Moral ist zwar einfach, aber sie hat bei mir trotzdem das Bezweck.
War es denn der Erkenntnisgewinn durchs Schauen der Serie? Oder war es auch die soziale Kommunikation mit anderen Leuten, die auch, wie heißt es, Bronys waren?
Das kann ich so gar nicht direkt beantworten. Ich glaube, am Anfang war es einfach so diese Neugierd dadurch, das Leben so, ich sage jetzt mal, neu zu entdecken, sage ich jetzt mal ausgedrückt, aber im Endeffekt war es dann auch, dass wir den anderen Leuten reden, auf andere Leute zugehen, einfach das Leben anfangen neu zu geließen auf diese Art und Weise. Einfach die kleinen Dinge genießen und wie es halt da immer wieder beschrieben wird, sage ich jetzt mal.
Okay, würdest du das anderen Leuten auch empfehlen? Guck dich das mal an, weil da kann man Erkenntnis rausziehen.
Also empfehlen würde ich auf jeden Fall, ich meine, also mich hat das dazu gebracht, diesen Thema Fanfiction, ich übersetze die Englischen sehr gerne auf Deutsch und davon habe ich…
Hoffentlich besser als die offiziellen Übersetzungen.
Bitte?
Ja, also ich habe jetzt immer nur ein gutes Feedback auf DeviantArt bekommen. Und also ich habe My Little Dashie, das ist die bekannteste, einer der bekanntesten Fanfics, die ist wirklich sehr traurig, 26 Seiten stark. Die habe ich übersetzt, einfach um die Geschichte zu teilen. Und ich wollte auch keine Gegenleistung haben, einfach aus Freude, weil mir einer der anderen schon ein Danke genug war.
Du hast das übersetzt, bist du aber nicht in Versuchen gekommen, dich auch mal selber zu versuchen?
Ja, also ein Freund hat mich mal zu einem Brainstorming einer Fanfiction überredet, aber das Problem ist einfach, ich prokrastiniere dann sehr viel und im Endeffekt wird das dann einfach nie wirklich was.
Bevor wir mit der Geschichte anfangen, gucken wir noch eine Folge My Little Pony.
Bitte?
Bevor wir mit der Geschichte anfangen, guck dir dann noch eine Folge My Little Pony, oder wie?
Nö, wir haben die immer zusammen live im Stream angeschaut damals. Jetzt kamen wir leider letzten Wochenende der Staffelfinale. Davor haben wir uns immer im Teamspeak getroffen bzw. im Skype, haben ein bisschen vor der Folge gequatscht, was könnte passieren, wie könnte es ausgehen. Und dann während der Folge haben wir in den Werbepausen immer die letzte Szene besprochen und die letzte Stunde danach haben wir dann halt über die ganze Folge geredet und diskutiert und haben uns gefreut darüber.
Also, die Zuschauer zu Hause sehen das jetzt nicht, aber ich glaube, Markus fällt gleich vor den Konzernfisch. Das ist eine sehr glückliche, mach ihn sehr glücklich.
Ich bin auf jeden Fall fasziniert davon. Also ich bin das immer wieder, weil gerade als Journalist beschäftigt man sich immer wieder mit Themen und ich bin immer wieder fasziniert, dass es egal worum es geht, es gibt diese tiefe Lust daran, etwas wirklich zu zelebrieren. Und das fand ich immer großartig. Ludwig, dir auf jeden Fall viel Spaß noch dabei. So, jetzt ist gerade hinter den Kulissen drüber geredet worden, dass es ja in dieser Fanfiction-Anteilung auch die dunkleren Kapitel gibt. Tina? Ich habe ja etwas von Horror und Slasher irgendwie jetzt im Hinterkopf. Gibt es sowas für die kleinen süßen Ponys etwa auch?
Ja, ich hab da eine, die ist, das ist die bekannteste, die kennt wohl auch die Pony-Gemeinde. Die ist 1189 Seiten lang, zumindest jetzt hier. Ja, die hat mehrere Kapitel, also mehrere im Sinne von, ich glaube 20, 30 oder so. Die heißt Fallout Equestria. Die müssten eigentlich alle kennen, die sich so ein bisschen mit My Little Pony und Slashfiction beschäftigen. Soll ich mal einen Absatz vorlesen?
Kannst du kurz noch für die anderen sozusagen erklären, worum es da geht?
Das spielt in einer postapokalyptischen Welt. Und zwar gab es irgendwie, das hat sie auch erklärt, in der Einleitung, da ging es irgendwie darum, dass die Magie überhand nahm und dann haben sie sich alle gestritten. Und dann gab es irgendwie einen riesen radioaktiven Clash. Und es gab jedenfalls irgendwie eine Zerstörung von Equestria. Also so ganz klassischer postapokalyptischer Plot.
Also dazu müssen wir kurz sagen, Equestria ist die Welt, in der die Ponys leben. Kenterlott ist die Hauptstadt, das haben wir noch nicht richtig eingeführt.
Genau, Ponyville ist irgendwie das Dorf, wo die da alle rumbringen. Und jetzt ist es so, es gibt unterirdische Bunker, die heißen Stables, also Ställe. Und in diesen Ställen leben jetzt diese Ponys sozusagen unterirdisch, haben noch nie mehr das Sonnenlicht gesehen, weil oben gibt es ja offensichtlich nichts. Das ist die Geschichte eines dieser Ponys. Dieses Pony hat auch einen Namen, habe ich jetzt vergessen. Oh Gott, habe ich vergessen. Und das ist kein so besonders spezielles Pony, also das fühlt sich nicht so besonders special. Und das geht dann auf einmal aus diesen Stables raus in diese postapokalyptische Welt, die bevölkert ist von auch Ponys, aber diese Ponys sind dem nicht so wohl gesinnt. Das ist mehr so The Road mit Ponys. Ja, nicht Mutanten, aber so ein bisschen so. Ja, wir müssen überleben und deswegen müssen wir euch jetzt leider tippen und vorher und so. Also, das ist alles zu erwachsen.
Okay, also Mutantenponys gibt es ja nicht, da muss ich wohl selber mal was schreiben und du kriegst uns jetzt einen kleinen Absatz daraus vor.
Genau, das ist allerdings auf Englisch. Ich hoffe, das ist kein Problem. Auf Deutsch habe ich das nicht gefunden. Ich sah kaum die Vorleger des Radar-Pony am Ende des Türschirms. Mit einem zweiten Gedanken levitierte ich das Tisch, damit es eine Barrikade auf der unteren Hälfte des Türschirms geformt hat und nach hinten gerannt hat. Die Geschichte ist tatsächlich relativ, also ich fand die sehr spannend. Ich bin jetzt irgendwie auf Seite, ich glaube 56 von 1189. Die ist lesbar, die ist auch sehr spannend und sie ist ziemlich gruselig. Also ich fand sie ziemlich gruselig. Also da werden ständig Ponys gekillt.
Gut, so ich möchte natürlich auch noch mal über die, also über Kritiken sozusagen nachher noch mal sprechen an der Serie, die es möglicherweise gibt. Jetzt noch mal ein kleiner Ausflug woanders hin. Stella aus Berlin hat angerufen und ist in Fanfiction in einem anderen Bereich unterwegs. Hallo Stella.
Hallo. Also Fanfiction an sich schreib ich jetzt selber nicht, aber ich denk mal, wenn man Anime guckt, Manga liest, dann stößt man auch unweigerlich darauf. Und das ist denke ich mal meistens auch Slashfiction. Ich weiß nicht, inwieweit man darüber jetzt hier so großartig reden kann.
Um die Uhrzeit. Was genau planst du?
Explizite Sexualakte beschreiben?
Nein. Nein. Es gibt ja eigentlich so einen großen, das nennt sich ja Dojinshi. Das sind ja praktisch bei Animefiguren, lässt sich ja auch recht einfach zeichnen, weil das eben von vornherein schon gezeichnet ist und eben kein echten Menschen sind. Und das ist eben so, dass dann bei den populären Serien dann auch immer in großen Massen so was rauskommt und sich auch recht schnell im Internet finden lässt. Und das ist eigentlich, also soweit ich weiß, dass 90 Prozent davon werden wohl sexuell sein, also Slashfiction. Aber...
Und das findest du besonders faszinierend? Oder wie kommst du darauf, deswegen hier anzurufen?
Nein, nein, das ist an sich nicht faszinierend. Aber worauf ich hinausfahre, ist, dass es wirklich dabei teilweise, was man auch gar nicht erwartet, wirklich gute Geschichten gibt. Ich kann jetzt wohl schlecht Beispiele nennen. Aber eben da, wo man es auch gar nicht erwartet, gibt es gute Geschichten. Aber das ist eigentlich nur der eine Punkt. Der andere Punkt ist, dass es eben das, was nicht Slashfiction ist, das kommt eher seltener vor. Aber wenn ich mal ein Beispiel nennen kann, ich glaube im Winter war das, da ist ein Anima rausgekommen, der hieß Goaty Crown. Und da haben Leute einfach sich hingesetzt und haben den Praktische umgeschrieben, dass er ein Spiel werden könnte. Sie haben da das System aufgeschrieben, wie es funktionieren könnte. Und wenn sich jetzt jemand noch bereit erklären würde, das zu machen, dann könnte man darauf schon ein Spiel programmieren. Es ging also.
Ah, du suchst jetzt hier Leute, oder?
Nein, nein, das wollte ich nur mal erzählen. Und jetzt frage ich mich, kennt ihr Katawashoujo? Ihr hattet ja vorhin auch über Fortschreien geredet. Und es hat ja auch da angefangen das Projekt. Das ist praktisch auch ein Spiel. Da haben wir glaube ich vier oder fünf Jahre dran gesessen.
Ah, ich glaube, ich habe davon schon mal gehört, aber ich bin nicht tief drin.
Okay, Stella, das wäre jetzt wahrscheinlich eine völlig neue Baustelle. Ich würde folgendes vorschlagen. Es gibt vom Chaos Computer Club betrieben ein Wiki zu dieser Sendung. Da kann man also Dinge reinschreiben. Wie wäre es, wenn du dorthin gehst und diese ganzen Punkte einmal aufschreibst, dann können Leute, die das interessiert, das nochmal nachschlagen. Chaosradio.de ist die Domain und dann einfach da auf Wiki klicken und dann das da eintragen. Möglicherweise findet sich dann auch noch ein Spieleprogrammierer. Vielen Dank für deinen Anruf und viel Spaß noch. So, ich bin ein bisschen überfallen von der ganzen, seine große Welt tut sich auf. Ich möchte jetzt jetzt nochmal kurz fragen, wir hatten es im Vorbereitung zur Sendung kurz irgendwie sexistische Tendenzen bei den Ponys. Kann man das so sagen oder ist das zu hart für eine so weiche Serie?
Na, das kann man schon sagen. Also alle Hauptfiguren sind weiblich. Es gibt sehr wenig männliche Figuren. Das ist auch einer der faszinierenden Punkte, warum sich sehr viele, also die Bronikultur ja hauptsächlich männlich ist, obwohl eigentlich kaum eine Figur weiblich männlich ist. Genau, die männlichen Figuren, die vorkommen, dürfen so Dinge tun wie Kutschen ziehen. Das muss man sich mal bildlich vorstellen. Also das ist halt eine Pferdekutsche, gezogen von Ponys, in der ein Pony sitzt. Und die Ziehpferde dürfen dann Männer sein. Männliche Ponys dürfen Bedienung im Restaurant sein. Der Süßigkeiten-Laden wird von einem Ehepaar betrieben. Da kommt doch also nochmal ein Mann vor. Und die anderen Männer... Ach ja, genau. Es gibt in der Schulklasse, es gibt also in der Serie eine Schulklasse, da sind tatsächlich zwei Jungs drin. Das sind aber mehr so Dösbattel, die halt nichts auf die Reihe kriegen und deswegen dauernd in Probleme geraten, weil sie halt zu blöd sind. Und dann kommt natürlich noch der große Bruder von Applejack, der kommt in ungefähr der Hälfte der Folgen vor, sagt, hat aber glaube ich nur in einer Folge eine längere Sprechrolle. Er sagt in allen anderen Folgen so, ist quasi ein Running-Gag, sagt er immer nur Jupp oder Nope. Das ist sehr einsilbig dargestellt, die männlichen Figuren der Serie. Erst im Staffelfinale und alle Leute, die es noch nicht gesehen haben, können jetzt vielleicht mal kurz, keine Ahnung, müssen jetzt Pause machen und dann erst die Folge gucken. Im Staffelfinale kommt dann tatsächlich eine ausnahmslos positiv und sehr breit dargestellte männliche Figur vor, die allerdings per quasi nachträglich eingebaut wurde. Also die wird halt dargestellt, als war schon immer da, wurde aber noch nie auch nur mit einer Silbe erwähnt bisher. Ist aber tatsächlich eine sehr starke, positiv dargestellte männliche Figur.
Jetzt ist das ja, wenn man sagt, okay, wenn man sich jetzt als die über 20-jährigen jungen Männer sich diese Serien angucken, dann ist das möglicherweise nicht schlimm, weil die unter Umständen reflektiert genug sind oder werden. Aber wenn das jetzt das Zielpublikum sechsjährige Mädchen sind, ist das dann schon was, wo man sagen könnte, es ist eigentlich nicht so großartig, weil die dann damit sozialisiert werden, dass es diese Geschlechtertrennung gibt?
Ah, unklar, in die Diskussion würde ich mich ungern verrennen.
Okay.
Also was auf jeden Fall auffällig ist, ist, dass im Bereich dazwischen mit so Teenagern, also wie gesagt, ich hatte ja schon mal dieses Teen's Reactor erwähnt, dass es da, also dass da die Reaktion hauptsächlich auch sehr stark darauf abzielen, dass also ein Teenager-Mann, ein junger Mann, der vielleicht in seiner Sexualität noch nicht so gefestigt ist, das doch dann mit sehr stark, sehr stark ablehnen muss, um nicht als scharfer Außenhund zu erscheinen.
Wobei ja My Little Pony tatsächlich als Aspekt von Performing Gender, also wenn wir jetzt über die E-Bronies reden, die männliche Zielgruppe, wenn sich jemand offen zu My Little Pony bekennt, dann ist das auf jeden Fall auch so ein Bekenntnis zu eben was niedlichem, was kleinem, etwas, was irgendwie als aus dem Feminin-Gender-Spektrum kommend so Stereotyp bekannt ist. Und das finde ich ganz, ganz toll. Weil es dann halt so ein bisschen diese Auflösung dieser starren Rollenbilder, ja. Ich bin, ich kann durchaus irgendwie ein selbstidentifizierter männlicher Mann sein mit irgendwie mit männlichen Vorlieben und ich gucke trotzdem kleine Ponys.
Ja, das finde ich auch, das fasziniert mich auch. Also ich bin da auch sehr kurz erst quasi damit mit mir im Reimen und so dermaßen nach außen auftretend.
Dass man beobachtet es also auch sich selbst, dass man eigentlich denkt, man ist reflektiert und erwachsen und hat natürlich kein Problem, aber dann stellt man fest, da ist doch diese Barriere irgendwie, oder wie ist dir das ergangen? Also dass du sagen, dass du dich überlegt hast, gebe ich das jetzt zu oder nicht?
So in etwa ja, also dass ich jetzt quasi in meiner Männlichkeit gefässigt bin, dass das geht.
Interessant, wofür die kleinen Ponys alle gut sein können. Wir sprechen gleich noch eine halbe Stunde drüber. Vorher machen wir aber das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr.
Genau, das war der Vorspann für die Leute, die es wissen. Das war tatsächlich die zweite Staffel. Ich glaube, da gibt es einen kleinen Unterschied in den musikalischen Darbietungen.
Herzlich willkommen. Ihr seid beim Chaosradio in Blue Moon auf Ritz und wir sprechen heute über Ponys. Tatsächlich sprechen wir heute über Fanfiction, über einen Teil der Nerdkultur und das erklärt am Beispiel der Serie My Little Pony, Friendship is Magic. Oh mein Gott, wo sind wir nur gelandet. Tatsächlich rufen heute selten viele Leute an beim Chaosradio, weil es um diese komische Fernsehserie geht. Ich weiß nicht genau...
Habe ich dir doch gesagt, dass Phänom sehr viele Leute mobilisieren können.
Das sind diese 1200 Leute der Fanclubs, die wir hier im Chaosradio...
Ich glaube nicht alle, aber einige zumindest, ja.
Na gut, dann nehmen wir gleich nochmal den Luca mit dazu.
Ja, die Frage habe ich mich auch schon ausgestellt. Also ich habe zum ersten Mal auf YouTube gesehen, das ist die erste Folge, das war auf Deutsch übrigens.
Oh ja, ganz schlimm.
Ja, so schlimm war es auch wieder nicht.
Also der Vorspann, ich fragte wozu Freundschaft gut sein kann, doch dann botet ihr die Freundschaft mir an.
Oh, das ist ja schon dramatikalisch irgendwie.
Ja, reim dich oder ich feste dich. Okay, ja, Entschuldigung, ich wollte dich nicht unterbrechen, rede weiter.
Ich mach nichts. Ja, ich hab's angeschaut erstmal und dann dachte ich, Scheiße, wieso kann ich das toll finden? Ich fand's wirklich gut. Ich fand's gut, wusste aber nicht wieso. Hab dann, nach ein paar Tagen hab ich aus Langeweile, ich hatte echt keine Lust gehabt, irgendwas zu machen, einfach mal die erste Staffel komplett am Stück angeschaut, das war neun Stunden, übrigens, am Stück durch und dann, ich war einfach baff.
Okay, hast du dich dann auch mal mit Fanfiction beschäftigt?
Ich wollte einmal eins schreiben, aber ich hab's dann aufgegeben, bevor es zwar begonnen hat und dann gelesen hab ich noch nicht, aber ich hol's immer mal nach.
Und worum sollte das gehen, was du schreiben wolltest?
Das sag ich lieber nicht.
Oh, Luca, na gut, das ist ein ungeschriebenes Werk. Aber wenn du's fertig hast, sagst du Bescheid, ja?
Wir lesen's dann im Radio vor.
Ich glaube, die lassen uns nach dieser Sendung nicht wieder rein.
Ich hab übrigens jetzt Slashfiction zu My Little Pony gefunden, falls ihr daran noch Interesse habt.
Machen wir vielleicht zum Abschluss der Sendung. Alles klar. So, Luca, würdest du anderen Leuten empfehlen, My Little Pony zu einen Start zu bringen?
Ich hab so einen Versuch von meinen Freunden und na, es ging gar nicht.
Was war die Reaktion?
Na ja, mein Kostän hat gesagt, du schaust dir eine Sendung an mit Ponys. Er hat ganz übrigens laut gesagt, meine Freunde, die haben gesagt, nee, vergiss es. Braucht gar nicht, damit wir erst ankommen, ne?
Okay, hast du dann, wir haben ja schon ein paar Leute hier am Telefon gehabt, die sagen, eine riesen Community, total geil, hast du dich dann noch miteinander zusammengetan, die das auch großartig finden?
Wie mein ich das jetzt?
Na irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Internetfonds, Kontakte geknüpft, keine Ahnung, weiß nicht.
Ja, ich war auch ein Fan, das war mal in Frankfurt.
Ah, gab es auch Verkleidete? Da gibt es aber noch was nachzuholen.
Ich persönlich war ja, ich fand das ja auf dem letzten Chaos Communication-Kongress sehr schön, da hatten sich dann auch spontan quasi Leute auf dem Flur zusammengefunden, haben einen der Fernseher gekapert und darauf eine Folge geguckt. Ich bin ja auch so ein Haarfärbe-Fan und hatte mir ja auch für den Kongress passend meine Haare gefärbt in Twilight-Sparkle-Manier. Ich hatte auch das passende Horn dazu mit einem 3D-Drucker ausgedruckt und mir ein T-Shirt zur Hand gemacht. Also nicht vollständig Cosplay, aber in die richtige Richtung geht.
Also Leute, lasst euch eure Zunge zergehen, ja? The Pinnacle of Technical Evolution, ein 3D-Drucker, wird dazu benutzt, dass Leute sich Hörner ausdrucken um...
Ja, Selbstrealisation, hey!
Was genau heißt das?
Naja, sich selber verwirklichen können, mit Technik, ist doch prima.
Und ausgelöst durch eine kleine Fernseher. Luca, dir viel Spaß damit noch.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Bis dann, tschüss. So, dann haben wir noch den Patrick, ebenfalls ein Fan. Patrick?
Ja, hallo. Ja, ich hab das ganze Thema eben bei uns im Forum mitbekommen. Ein Kollege hat mir das gesagt, dass ihr da heute über das Thema redet. Und da wollte ich einfach mal auch mich dazu äußern. Aus dem einfachen Grund, weil ich kann es eigentlich jedem nur empfehlen, der wirklich gute Zeichentrickserien, sich auch alte Zeichentrickserien gern angeguckt hat. My Little Pony ist einfach wirklich gemacht wie die älteren Zeichentrickserien, die ich aus meiner Kindheit auch kenne. Es ist wirklich eine tolle Sache. Die Folgen sind komplett gut durchdacht und auch wunderbar gezeichnet. Und ich kann es eigentlich nur wirklich jedem empfehlen, es selber mal anzugucken, eventuell als Anlaufadresse auch mal bronis.de zu gehen. Das ist glaub ich deutschlandweit auch die größte Internet-Community. Ich bin da selber angemeldet. Wir haben knapp 1.700 User dort.
Patrick, ist denn das Faszinierende für dich, die Serie hat man immer geguckt, ist das dann auch die Leute, die dazugehören?
Es ist auch rein vom Fandom her eins der stärkst vertretenen, die ich im Internet bis jetzt selber miterlebt habe. Und es ist ja wirklich so, wenn man sich mit den Leuten kurzschließt, man kann sich jeden Abend im TS mit denen unterhalten, sie sind eigentlich immer da, wenn man wirklich mal ein Problem hat. Die helfen auch einem in anderen Formen oder Fandoms, habe ich schon erlebt. Die lassen einen dann trotzdem einfach hängen. Die sagen halt, ja, Pech für dich. Aber da ist wirklich ein Zusammenhalt da. Also die Serie schweißt wirklich Leute zusammen.
Hast du denn sich selber schon mal an Fanfiction probiert?
Nein, ich bin aber auf Bronies.de leidenschaftlich RPG-Schreiber.
Du musst kurz die drei Buchstaben erläutern.
Das sind RPGs und ich bin in einem zum Beispiel vertreten. Das heißt Luna Republic. Da geht es mehr um Kriegsszenario, wo das Ganze abspielt.
Das ist ein RPG-Role-Playing-Game?
Also sie sagen, ihr versetzt euch in die Rolle eines Ponys und in die Rolle eines Ponys und spielt dann sozusagen Geschichten aus dieser Welt nach. Per Text.
Wir schreiben unsere eigenen, komplett eigene Ideen und alles werden einfließen gelassen. Es ist einfach eine wunderbare Sache zum sehen, wie Leute dann auf einzelne Aktionen, die man selber macht, reagieren. Man kann einfach wirklich eine schöne Geschichte dann auch daraus zusammenfassen.
Fanfiction The Next Step quasi. Patrick, die viel Spaß noch damit. Kann man das, Tina, doch dazu zählen, zu Fanfiction? Oder ist das dann schon nochmal was ganz anderes Neues?
Aus deinem Universitätsumfeld?
Das gehört da auf jeden Fall mit rein. Das ist halt kollaboratives Fanfiction schreiben. Das ist nochmal, das ist lustig. Das ist The Next Step. Normalerweise hat man ganz klare Rollenverteilung. Es gibt den Autor der Fanfiction-Geschichte. Dann gibt es noch den Leser, also den Korrekturleser und nochmal den Kommentator sozusagen, Beta-Reader. Das ist so eine Rollenverteilung in der Fanfiction-Gemeinde. Das wird da jetzt so ein bisschen aufgehoben und durch kollaboratives Schreiben ersetzt. Das finde ich aber super.
Was wir heute auch noch alles lernen. So, dann haben wir noch den Martin. Ja, hallo. Auch ein Pony-Fan. Warum?
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Ich habe, wie gesagt, die Bilder im Internet überall gesehen und damals aus Interesse halt einfach mal geguckt, was steckt denn dahinter. Und ja, angefangen bei Folge 1. Und ja, ich konnte einfach nicht mehr aufhören.
Und hast du dich auch mal selber an Fan-Faction probiert?
Na ja, ich habe mich mal dran probiert, aber ist nicht so gut geworden, sage ich mal.
Warum nicht? Woran ist es gescheitert?
Ich bin nicht so der Schreiberling, sage ich mal. Und ja, es war halt, wie soll ich sagen, mehr so auf Erotik bezogen, als aber eher in Comedy abgedriftet ist.
Slashfiction, wir haben einen Slashfiction-Schreiber am Telefon. Hast du es mal jemanden zu lesen gegeben, oder hast du dann selber entschieden, so, ne, ne, das geht nicht?
Naja, ich hab's mal hier meinen, ja, Leuten, mit denen man so im Teamspeak oder auf Facebook so in Kontakt ist, ja, vorgestellt. Die fanden es mehr lustig, zum Teil auch, ja, weiß ich nicht, von der Ausdrucksweise ein bisschen hart, ja, aber es war mehr...
Okay, da müsste also nochmal dran gefeilt werden, entnehme ich dem? Hast du denn, hast du schon gute Fanfiction gelesen?
Gelesen, ja, so My Little Dashie, die Klassiker, ja, und muss sagen, My Little Dashie kann ich auf jeden Fall empfehlen. Es ist eine ziemlich traurige Geschichte.
Oh, okay, kann man's auch merken. Martin, vielen Dank. Und viel Spaß noch. Bis dann. Tschüss. So, jetzt haben wir fast schon zwei Stunden über My Little Pony geredet. Gibt es irgendwas, was wir noch vergessen haben?
Na, was man auf jeden Fall noch mal kurz anreißen kann. Viele Leute haben vielleicht sogar schon mal was von den Ponys gehört, auch wenn sie es nicht aktiv mitgekriegt haben. Denn eines der Lieblingsthemen der Berichterstattung über die Piratenpartei, zumindest in Berlin, war ja immer die Ponytime. Es gibt nämlich auch unter den Piraten viele, zumindest Fans der Serie, wenn vielleicht nicht auch gleich voll ausgewachsene Ponys, aber Leute, die es nicht hassen. Und sie haben in die Geschäftsordnung der Berliner Piratenpartei, zumindest, weiß nicht, ob es bei der Bundespiratenpartei auch so ist, haben sie mehr oder weniger reingeschmuggelt einen Geschäftsordnungsantrag auf Ponytime. Das ist eine sehr lustige Geschichte, die sie dann auch immer gerne erzählen, so quasi so morgens, noch nicht alle da und noch nicht ganz wach, das ist noch nicht so richtig, worüber abgestimmt wird und da wird halt quasi dieser Geschäftsordnungsantrag, die wird halt dann quasi aufgenommen. Und seitdem gibt es bei der Berliner Piratenfraktion in der Geschäftsordnung einen Geschäftsordnungsantrag auf Ponytime. Das läuft dann so ab, dass jeder das beantragen kann, Ponytime beantragen kann. Die Versammlungsleitung sucht dann eine, der Grund dafür ist, wenn es gerade zu hitzig hergeht, zu heiß hergeht in der Diskussion, wenn die Gemüter erregt sind, wenn keiner mehr auf den anderen hört, dann kann man Ponytime beantragen. Die Versammlungsleitung sucht dann eine passende Folge raus. Wie gesagt, die haben ja alle jeweils eine dedizierte Moral. Ich glaube, es gibt kein ordentliches Mapping. Dazu muss man vielleicht nochmal aufrufen, so eine Liste von Moral zu Folge. Aber wenn man sie gesehen hat, kann man das vielleicht einigermaßen aus dem Kopf machen. Wird dann also eine Folge rausgesucht, abgespielt und in der Zeit beruhigen sich die Gemüter dann hoffentlich wieder.
Okay, also man muss dazu sagen, das ist jetzt nicht nur der Scherz, der da gemacht wurde, sondern es ist tatsächlich sagen, in dem, also in dieser Geschäftsordnung, in der Partei...
Es ist in der Geschäftsordnung drin und wurde schon zweimal, glaube ich, angewendet.
Bestimmt nur in Berlin. In Bayern gibt es das sicherlich nicht.
Ja, ich glaube in Berlin und bundesweit. Aber ich bin mir bei bundesweit nicht sicher. Bei Berlin weiß ich es relativ genau. Sie schreiben auch, man darf es da natürlich nicht übermäßig anwenden, sondern gezielt und mit Maßen. Aber ja, es scheint wohl zu funktionieren.
Das ist halt offiziell.
Das ist allen anderen Parteien zu empfehlen.
Wolltest du noch die Geschichte mit dem fehlenden Klinkenkabel erzählen?
Es gab dann tatsächlich wohl mal auf einer Versammlung, diesmal einer Bundesversammlung, glaube ich, hat jemand einen Antrag auf Ponytime gestellt. Ich habe das auch nur indirekt mitgekriegt. Und da war die Versammlungsleitung nicht darauf vorbereitet, hatte also kein Klinkenkabel in ihrem Laptop drin. Sie haben also die erste Folge abgespielt auf dem Beamer. Und dann mussten zwei Leute, Lapentin und Fou, glaube ich, Handmikrofon in der Hand und haben dann mehr oder weniger frei, vielleicht nicht richtig synchronisiert, aber doch sehr frei, dazu gesprochen, was gerade auf dem Bildschirm passiert. Und es war ein großer Spaß für alle, auch auf YouTube zu sehen.
Gibt es davon eine Aufnahme?
Es gibt eine Aufnahme.
Sehr schön. Bitte liebe Hörer, es gibt ein Wiki zum Chaosradio. Tragt bald den Link ein, ich möchte mir das auch gerne angucken. Ponys, nicht endwollende Geschichte.
Ja genau, wenn man schon bei Links ist, kann man dann später noch verlinken, wenn ihr mehr über Ponys erfahren wollt. Ich persönlich bin mir mehr so mit den amerikanischen Ressourcen vertraut. Also von diesen Deutschen höre ich jetzt doch fast zum ersten Mal. Im amerikanischen Sprachraum ist also ein großes Blog Equestria Daily. Also Equestria hatten wir ja schon, war das Land. Dazu gibt es dann auch ein IRC-Server, ein IRC-Netzwerk, Canternet mit einem eigenen Kanal, Equestria Daily, wo sich dann halt Leute treffen können und reden können. Bronys treffen können und reden können. Es gibt wichtige Ressourcen bei Wikia. Also Wikia, ich weiß nicht, wer das Projekt kennt. Das ist quasi so eine Art themenspezifische Wikipedia. Also kann jeder ein Wiki einrichten zu einem bestimmten Thema. Und da gibt es halt vor allen Dingen zu Fankulturen. Also Lost ist ganz groß gewesen. Lost, Battlestar Galactica und so weiter. Da gibt es dann also eigene Wikis und auch zu My Little Pony. mlpwikia.com Und was mich halt, als ich es zum ersten Mal gesehen habe, tatsächlich sehr... Na, ich will jetzt nicht überrascht sagen, aber doch sehr... Ja, doch überrascht hat. War My Little Wiki dort nett, glaube ich. Das ist dann also eine Auflistung nicht zu dieser Zeichensrickserie, sondern zu dem My Little Pony Universum allgemein, also zu den Plastikfiguren seit den 80ern. Und dort gibt es, wie gesagt, auch diese Liste mit den 1000 oder so Ponys oder 2000 mit Fotos und allem Drum und Dran, identifizierenden Merkmal. Da kann man sich also, wenn man einen Pony gefunden hat, gucken, welches es ist.
Ja, da haben wir schon stundenlang nach diesem einen doofen Pony gesucht.
Genau, wenn man mal ein Bild irgendwo findet von einem tatsächlich existierenden Plastikpony, will man es natürlich identifiziert haben.
Sehr schön, jetzt wollte ich gerade noch was fragen. Ach so, gebeten worden hier im Chat, es gibt wohl einen Podcast hier in Deutschland?
Es gibt mehrere. Wenn ich gehört habe, habe ich zuletzt den Ponytime Podcast. Auch wenn ich hier mal als Experte genannt wurde, gegen Gerjad, kann ich da jetzt nicht so richtig anstinken. Das ist also auch sehr ausführlich und lehrreich, wenn man mehr über das Universum und die Hintergründe und die Macher erfahren möchte. Das gibt es auch im englischen, das ist dann Bronyville, also quasi der Hauptpodcast dazu, mit ganz vielen Episoden und furchtbar langen Episoden, die wahrscheinlich dann alles in aller Ausführlichkeit erklären.
Okay, falls ihr noch nicht genug davon bekommen könnt. So rum, wie ist es denn eigentlich mit einer neuen Staffel? Ich habe jetzt gehört, es gibt zwei, die laufen gerade.
Genau, die Staffelfinale war letztes Wochenende, wenn ich mich gerade nicht täusche. Es wird im September wieder neue Folgen geben. Wir warten also jetzt alle gespannt darauf. Vielleicht gibt es in der Zwischenzeit mehr Fanfiction, wer weiß.
Können wir sehen. Tina, noch die eher allgemeinere Frage, jetzt gar nicht auf Ponys bezogen. Gibt es im Bereich der Fanfiction etwas in die Zukunft geblickt, was da möglicherweise eine größere Rolle spielen würde? Also ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel gehört, da gibt es zum ersten Mal Zusammenarbeit zwischen Firmen, die ein Massive Multiplayer Online Role-Playing Game machen wollen und dazu eine Fernsehserie drehen. Gibt es so Kollaborations-Dinge, die ihren Weg dann nach ganz oben schaffen? Sag ich mal, gibt es da Aufsichten, dass sowas in Zukunft eine größere Rolle spielen wird?
Ich würde jetzt mal sagen, bestimmt. Also da die partizipative Natur des Internets ja immer wichtiger wird, auch im Reallife und diese Grenzen einfach auch viel mehr verschwimmen, ist Fan-Kultur einfach etwas, was man nicht so richtig ignorieren mehr kann. Und wie wir auch gehört haben, es gibt richtig gute Fan-geschriebene Geschichten, und fantastische Communities, die sehr, sehr einverdreichend kreativ sind. Und ich denke mal, dass das einfach auch in Zukunft wichtig sein wird, auch auf diese Fans zu hören, weil das sehr, sehr aktive und sehr loyale Fans sind.
Was werdet ihr als nächstes für eine Fan-Fiction schreiben? Oh Gott, in dieser Sendung, in der ich sozusagen ein und das andere Mal das Auge und die Auge auch mal verwundert war, jetzt hättet ihr gerade Henrys Gesicht sehen sollen. Als ich nach seiner Fan-Fiction, die er noch schreiben wird, gefragt hab.
Ich bin da so wenig der Schreiber. Also wenn ich schreibe, sind es mehr Programme, glaube ich.
Also Markus schreibt jetzt als nächstes was über Mutantenponys. Klar, warten wir alle drauf. Sefa hat uns ja jetzt schon Links gegeben. Die hab ich jetzt auch alle gerade mal in den Twitter getan. Mein Twitter nick ist tweener. Diese Links, da geht's dann schon mal um Mutantenponys. Da hat jemand diese Plastikponys nämlich genommen und mit so Knete und Fimo zu Mutantenponys verarbeitet. Auch ein ganz interessanter Beitrag zur Fan-Kultur.
Okay, super. Haben wir uns auch noch Mutantenponys umgebracht. So, wir haben jetzt noch einen Anrufer, den nehmen wir noch ganz kurz rein und dann ist auch gleich Schluss.
Marc?
Als letzter Anrufer-Fan?
Ja, richtig. Und zwar habe ich mich dazu geschaltet, weil ich, also ich bin jetzt gerade erst dazugekommen, auch zum Stream vom Radio und ich wollte im Endeffekt wissen, also beziehungsweise wollte ich gerade noch das Thema übergreifend sagen, was jetzt Massive-Multiplayer-Online-Games betrifft. Ich persönlich bin momentan mit einem amerikanischen Team am Arbeiten und arbeite dort momentan als freiberuflicher Designer, sage ich jetzt mal. Und wir bereiten momentan für die große BronyCon, die jetzt in zwei Monaten circa läuft, ein Multiplayer-Online-Spiel vor, ein 2D. Das Ganze nennt sich MLP Online, endefektlich. Und dort soll man dann, wie man das kennt, Quests lösen. Man kriegt Events, es gibt eine Art Kampfsystem, was sich ziemlich an alte Final Fantasy Teile ansiedelt. Also sowas ist auf jeden Fall das, was ich mache.
Ein Online-Rollenspiel im My Little Pony-Universum, ist das offiziell oder ist das auch eine Fanart?
Das ist momentan eine fan-based Sache, die wird aber offiziell mit Stand auf der BronyCon halt aufgeführt und vorgestellt. Und wir versuchen dann im Endeffekt mit diesem Produkt und diesem Spiel verschiedene, nicht nur die Leute in der Szene, sprich die Brony, sondern auch wirklich Leute außerhalb, also ein bisschen dem Thema näherzubringen. Und das halt dann auf die spielerische Weise.
Um Gottes Willen, jetzt gibt es auch noch ein Online-Rollenspiel. Sag mal kurz noch den Namen.
Das Game wird MLP Online heißen. Da gibt es auch eine Gruppe zu und eine Homepage mit vorhandenem Trailer.
Okay, Marc, weil die Zeit schon knapp ist, könntest du uns auch einen Gefallen tun und das ins Wiki zur Sendung schreiben.
Noch ganz kurz danke Marc, dass er uns dran erinnert hat. Es gibt natürlich auch Cons dazu mit Leuten, die sich dann im Reallife treffen und ganz groß wie bei vielen anderen Dingen. Damit haben wir dann den Kreis zur Hackerkultur wieder geschlossen. Es gibt Cons, wo sich Leute in der realen Welt treffen und es gibt halt diesen Community-Zusammenhalt und Leute helfen sich gegeneinander, wie auch in der Hackerkultur.
So, wir haben jetzt gleich noch ein kleines Schmanker für euch. Ich bin ja eigentlich zwei kleine Schmanker, denn es gibt in diesem Bereich Fanarbeit. Natürlich auch Leute, die sich mit der Musik von den Ponys beschäftigt haben. Und da hab ich noch einen kleinen Track gefunden, da ist... Wie heißt das? Pinkie? Okay, Party with Pinkie Pie heißt der Track von LXS. Ich find den super.
Genau, das spaltet sich sehr.
Und bevor wir dazu kommen, verabschiede ich mich. Sag recht herzlichen Dank Henrik fürs Expertentum.
Ja, bitte.
Und Tina für die Einblicke in die Fanfiction. Und du hast jetzt noch ganz zum Schluss für alle Fans, bevor wir den Nightfight mit Flo Heiler und die Punk-Musik abgeben, ein kleines bisschen Horror.
Du darfst es jetzt nicht sparen.
Mann ey, das war so eine gute Einleitung. Okay, warte, wir müssen nochmal. Ich komm einfach nochmal rein.
Ja, bitte.
Und dann hast du noch ganz zum Schluss so ein kleines bisschen Horror.
She looked into his eyes and his heart fluttered slightly. Call me Rarity, came the whisper, before her lips pressed against his. It only lasted for a few seconds, but those few seconds were some of the best in his life. Her pillow-soft and lipstick-covered lips pulled away from his heart wind-chopped once, opening her massive deep blue eyes and staring up in his still shocked expression. Grinning deviously, as it quickly changed from shock to acceptance, he had clearly wanted this for a while.